foreign so uh we're live at Turning
Point USA this time we're actually in
this studio that they they built for us
it's really cool look behind us I don't
know if you do a wide shot real quick
there's a gigantic Tim cast IRL it feels
so amazing yeah welcome to the show here
we got everybody hanging out uh man
today was crazy I was I was glued to the
Cary Lake trial Shane Cashman who's here
was actually there at the trial all day
actually several hours before the trial
look at this Ian's playing
rookie mistakes mistakes so this is
crazy the big news I think there's
there's a bunch of witness testimony and
one of the key takeaways was when an
expert witness testified that there were
duplicate ballots and no Originals they
didn't know where the originals were he
said that when he was sampling the
ballots as per the court order he found
that they were duplicates one that these
were 19-inch ballot images but placed on
a 20 inch paper so they weren't being
read properly the whole thing sounds
crazy and then another witness testified
that there was no chain of custody and I
think what was a 298 000 ballots was
that what it was yeah and so then they
reported 275 plus right then there's no
chain of custody then they report 298.
so we need to see what that ultimately
leads to the the court is going to the
trial is going to continue tomorrow but
I'm sitting here like the the argument
from the defense is sure that may be but
is there any intent to have you know
broken chain of custody and that's the
argument they're making we will we'll
get in all that stuff we got a bunch of
other stories the FBI has responded to
the Twitter leaks saying it's a
conspiracy theory which is hilarious
because like we actually have their
emails the lenski met with Biden and uh
he gave him an award I guess then we
have this is surprising Kevin McCarthy
is coming out in opposition to the 1.7
trillion was it trillion right 1.7
trillion Omnibus seems like Marjory
Taylor green is getting to him and he
knows that he's got to actually start
taking a stand so we're going to get
into all that before we get started my
friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen from bio
trust this is can you guys get it on the
screen this is a collagen that you need
for your your joints your skin your
nails your bones and all that good stuff
if you go to strongerbones in life.com
right now you'll get 51 off and you will
also get a 60 day money back guarantee
bio trusts ageless multi collagen gives
you the healthy aging support of
collagen in ideal forms five key types
of collagen you need from four different
sources and for every order today
BioTrust will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kidhungry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of six million
meals this year it's non-GMO and free of
artificial colors flavors preserves and
sweeteners free of gluten antibiotics
and rbgh and rbsd nearly no odor or
taste unlike bone broth and other
collagen supplements no Clump clumping
unlike other supplements you'll get free
shipping with every order free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order so again
go to strongerbonesandlife.com thank you
BioTrust for sponsoring the show and
don't forget head over to timcast.com
click that join us button become a
member and you'll get access to the
uncensored members only show that we're
going to have up for you tonight around
11 p.m Eastern it's going to be I think
it'll be pretty awesome because we do
have a lot of a lot of stuff that we
want to talk about considering our guest
tonight so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and uh joining
us tonight to talk about this and so
much more is Mr Kyle Rittenhouse Tim
thank you for having me on my first time
I know we've tried before but get up in
that microphone forgot you have to speak
to the mic that's right that's right
bring it around with you oh thank you
for having me Tim we met actually uh
here a couple days ago here at America
Fest we met backstage and I thought that
was pretty cool and thank you for having
me on yeah so uh how do you describe
yourself I mean a lot of everybody knows
your story everyone but how do you
describe yourself how would you
introduce yourself
Kyle Redden house I have no idea the
name says it all just make it like
Madonna just be like writtenhouse well I
guess I guess you know it's it's what
are you working on these days you know I
want to get more involved in journalism
I'm still learning a lot I like honestly
have no idea what I'm doing I'm still
figuring it out I'm still trying to
articulate how to talk about some of
these topics figure out by watching you
guys watching Rogan watching other
people how they do it and just trying to
build my name build my platform and
become like an activist in a way for the
First Amendment the Second Amendment in
censorship right on you started a
YouTube channel too right I did I
haven't posted any content yet um I'm
still figuring out
um like how to make a studio and how to
film stuff and like maybe do like a
podcast style type deal one one of the
stories that we actually have that I
think we'll be interesting to talk about
is this Tech entrepreneur in Austin who
thought someone broke into his house so
he started he started sweeping his own
perimeter with it with his AR and the
cops roll up scream drop the gun within
a split second just open fire on him
killing him so this is a story that I
saw I really want to talk about
considering you know I'm very Pro to a
but more importantly because of all the
swattings I watched that video and I was
like that's what they want to happen to
us we should definitely talk about that
so Kyle thanks for hanging out and we
have joining us is uh Shane Cashman who
is actually at Cary Lake's trial all day
yeah yeah I'm so I'm stoked to be here
with you Kyle and I support the
journalism uh that's awesome I'm looking
forward to seeing journalism from you
man uh but yeah I was like careless I
got there so early that they thought I
was homeless like I had my big coat on
I'm just sitting outside it was like
four in the morning like what is this
guy doing here I'm like is it Carrie
Lake thing here today but thankfully it
was and it was it was incredible it was
a long day who were they well you know
what I'm gonna save it we'll get into it
we're talking about the trial then we
got uh we got of course lucr's here hey
guys Lou gradesky here if we are
changing a very simple message today
trust the government back the blue just
take the medical procedure get on the
train life's gonna be so much easier
when you're doing that's why I made my
shirts today that says we're the good
guys trust us if you want to fit in with
your Normie buddies and friends this is
the perfect Church to do it which you
could get on the best
politicalshorts.com because you guys do
that's why I'm here thank you we got Ian
of course yeah the rumors are true I
fell off the stage at uh America Fest at
the end of the show I was like keep it
real and then I turned and walked off I
you know the biggest problem was I
didn't inspect the stage before we did
the show and if you're ever gonna do
stage work you really got to take Safety
First make sure you know your
surroundings you know if there's cables
on the ground where the Pit's at all
that stuff fortunately I landed on my
feet did a little roll pulled my back a
little bit but I was stretching for the
last couple days I feel great I love
what you said later that night you were
like I'm really good at falling yeah
that's a positive turn there are some
things
if it was on video it would have been
viral no and that's the same thing I was
there right next to you I heard people
tell me they'll pay money for it so if
you've got the video I mean they may
have been filming with the other cameras
or whatever you know what I want to say
before we jump into this with with Luke
mentioning his shirt you got Biden
yelling it says we're the good guys
here's what I recommend I recommend you
buy the shirt from from uh Luke's best
politicalshirts.com right the best
political show the best and then when
you go when you go to Christmas if you
get it ship it overnight talk to your
family and friends like hello friend I
am also in agreement with you we are the
good guys and just like look past them
don't look at them and like move very
like methodically and robotically just
like an NPC exactly and be like hello
yes Biden is good
NPC sign up dinner all right let's jump
into the first story we have this from
12news.com Lakes expert witness
misprinted ballots would ultimately have
been counted Lake's team alleged that a
ballot sizing misprint disrupted the
election but Lake hired analyst clay
Parikh says the ballots would have been
counted in the end I'm going to pause
right there and say that is a gross
mischaracterization of what the witness
actually said do you agree Shane I agree
it's just like how they said she lost
the lawsuit by having eight things uh
dismissed but two going forward let me
let me read a little bit uh read a
little bit of this uh uh and then we'll
explain they say Carrie lake has two
days to convince the Maricopa County
superior court that her election loss
was caused by outside interference on
the first day of the trial and in
information security officer hired by
Lake's team said that misprinted ballots
would have been duplicated and counted
no he didn't he did not say that Lake
needs to prove that a specific Maricopa
County employee interfered with ballot
printers and that law lost enough votes
to cost her the election she also needs
to prove that alleged ballot drop-offs
cost her the elections Lake's legal team
originally planned to call Katie Hopps
to witness Lake even most of the Katie
hops will take the witness stand
all right let me let me just break down
for you what he actually said he said
that he inspected ballots they were
allowed to inspect I think was it like
50 pound man's melon ballots and
standard belts or whatever and that he
looked at 15 14 of which were was it 14
duplicates yeah and that the 15th was
torn right so all right so then they
said uh I think these duplicates were
these the ones that were 19-inch on 20
inch paper or was that he said most of
them were 19 and 10 20 inch paper so
that's a separate issue but here's
ultimately what I want to bring up with
this so we can start getting into it he
said the only way that the the image
could have been altered uh I got to slow
down because so it's this is how they
get intricate it's right so you got a 20
inch image that fits on a sheet of paper
for some reason these ballots were
printed at 19 inches but on the same
size paper a 20 inch piece of paper
meaning when the when the ballot printer
was trying to read it nothing was in the
right place so
it doesn't read it it rejects it what
happens then is people place them in box
number three and then when they're
trying to count them they duplicate that
ballot what he actually said was The
Originals were missing that a duplicate
existed with no original to account for
it then uh Katie Hobbs is Loyals
Maricopa County not Katie's Maricopa
County's lawyer comes up and says if a
ballot is duplicated doesn't get counted
and he goes that wouldn't be possible
it's like I'm asking you would it be
counted and he's like that's not
technically possible what the witness
was saying is the only way this error
could have occurred it was not an heir
the only way this misprint could
occurred is if someone bypassed security
and intentionally went in and altered
the printing mechanism therefore in this
instance it's not possible for you to
actually have that duplicate ballot made
and then counted so now you get the
media coming out and saying well you
know Carrie lake is saying that they it
would have been counted there's no issue
here
my bet the judge is going to come back
out using this narrative that they're
creating and say there's no evidence of
anything and you know sorry there's no
intent therefore case dismissed the
defense sets up a sound bite that sounds
good in the news the news runs with it
all the Nuance is lost and like because
there's a ton of nuance leading up to
all that and they set up a witness to
say uh I think it was their first
witness I said it's impossible for it to
we didn't have any 19-inch ballots in
this election not at all and then they
obviously teed it up for that you know
bombshell I thought he basically said
the only way for there to be a 19-inch
ballot image on a 20-inch piece of paper
is if someone either manipulated the
printers themselves bypassing security
or manipulated the software entering
passwords or bypassing security so it
could not have been an accident what was
really frustrating to me about watching
this this uh this this trial is that the
the Maricopa County lawyers and Katie
Hobbs team or whatever they're they're
doing these questions where they're like
so Luke when did you stop beating your
wife it's a simple question did you stop
beating your wife yesterday yes or no
and it's you're like how do I answer
that and then the judge goes look it's a
yes or no question answer it if you
don't understand say I don't understand
and then they're forcing the witnesses
to claim they don't understand because
otherwise it's a question that draws a
conclusion yeah I saw I saw as dimassing
them to prove the existence of God in
front of everybody because it was it
wasn't it wasn't simple it was a lot of
nuance and things going on like you were
saying it's so intricate how all these
things were happening and you can't just
say yes or no and it also proves uh just
how like convoluted the chain of custody
really is you know they're very like
reluctant to say yes or no proves that
to me at least what really frustrates me
is that they didn't do witness training
uh Carey Lake's team you you you you
have the witness and you explain to them
the opposing lawyers are going to try to
trick you I mean Kyle you know all about
this absolutely they're going to try to
get you to go down this rabbit hole and
they're gonna phrase things in a way
that yes or no either way you either way
you answer it it's going to sound bad no
matter what and and that's what they do
that's why it's important for them to
ask hey can you please rephrase that
question in another way that I can
understand it it doesn't sound that it
sounds a lot better if you ask them to
rephrase it but that's the crazy thing I
mean I feel like the judge
should be yelling at these lawyers like
you go up and you say something like did
you stop beating your wife yesterday or
the day before yeah we'll pick one which
one is it you're like what I don't beat
my wife right it's like that that's not
that's not responsive that's not what I
asked you that's crazy the judge was
getting impatient I mean there's a
certain point where it was hobbs's
attorney standing up constantly
objecting on grounds of foundation and
speculation and then they were like it's
all speculation this is what we're here
for literally yeah is that not
considered leading the witness when you
ask him a question with two pointed
answers that neither of which are
accurate I think that's a little
different when you're like I don't
really know but I think it's when you're
questioning expecting a certain thing
like you're leading down a path and
speculation is more just like the theory
behind it I could be wrong but like
that's because they they did get called
out earlier for leading the witness at
one point but the speculation was just
like because it was based on Theory I
guess there's a lot more as well
um correct me if I'm wrong but they had
a witness testify that 298 000 ballots
had no chain of custody I think that's
what they said yeah between like the
drop-offs and and I guess Red Bank I
forget right back run back right which I
tried to get into Yesterday they refused
you tried to go there I was there I
stood outside I was trying I watched the
sunrise over that place wow it's like a
walled off city right by the airport
it's a weird so this this witness
testifies that run back employees were
bragging about the perk of being able to
bring ballots into their job outside of
chain of custody and have them be
counted and the craziest thing is not
only that but that there was there's
supposed to be a chain of custody
receipt every step of the way and
there's one there's like three chain of
custody receipts and there's one missing
and they don't know how where these
ballots came from or or or what happened
they just basically they go from the
from the polling look from the voting
Center then there's no receipt then they
leave the voting Center and and they
pointed out that I think it was uh was
it richer who tweeted out 275 more than
275 000 ballots came in plus yeah and
then later said it was 299 and so so she
said obviously it's a round number so
it's not the exact number but then with
no chain of custody he's basically said
one number and then added an additional
20 some of that 22 000 23 000 ballots
but without a receipt we can't track
where those ballots came from the
craziest thing is the in in the trial
they're basically like yes
we understand but can you prove anyone
intended to to break the law right and
Maricopa I think it was the Maricopa it
was Lindy who's tried being like so you
just so we make sure this is clear you
know it's not illegal for the ballot
harvesting to get in to this and she
came back with a pretty great response
she's like it's not unlawful it's
invalid she's like that's the proper
terminology that was that was I was so
we're you know we're all hanging out and
I've got the live stream going while
we're trying to eat eat dinner and the
the it was a Maricopa lawyer I believe
Lindy yeah Lindy he comes out and he's
like would it surprise you to learn that
if someone brings a if someone brings in
a ballot uh illegally the ballot itself
is not illegal like I'm paraphrasing but
he basically said if you enter in a vote
into the system in less than legal means
you may have committed a crime but the
ballot itself can still be counted or
it's it's not illegal and then she goes
I believe that's called an invalid
ballot she was really good this is crazy
it makes me impressed with that the
corporate media's take on this is pretty
interesting because I just typed in Cary
Lake into the news that's happening on
Brave and the first two articles that
are popping up talking points memos
number one and it says Carrie Lake big
lie Circus Comes to court the second
article is by Newsweek on MSN saying
Carey Lake election trial married with
embarrassing mishaps so obviously I mean
this court proceeding is still going on
there's going to be another court date
tomorrow Robert Barnes has a different
perspective on this he just tweeted a
couple minutes ago Kerry Lake proved
everything she needed to today to win
her election contest that's what Barnes
is saying what's going to be the
decision here it's going to be
interesting because uh I think in 1994
there was a state senate election that
was overturned by a judge after there
was illegal ballot harvesting that was
ruled by him uh specifically in um in
the state election there so I don't know
what's going to happen here but this is
a very interesting court trial that I
think a lot of people have different
perspectives on depending on where
they're coming from politically am I am
I pessimistic to say I think that judge
is going to throw it out yeah
that's a form of pessimism you're right
I think I think that's gonna be yeah I
don't I do have hope because like I
think Barnes is on to something because
I I was impressed by uh not impressed
disgusted by the uh impressed and
disgusted by the like lack of security
the one witness is saying the ballots
were were kept in
I I was losing it because the the first
witness this guy clay he said the
ballots were not properly sealed they
had no security seal on the boxes just a
piece of red tape and then the the
defense witness so this is basically
Katie hops in Maricopa County goes was
the Box sealed and he goes there was no
security seal on it yes or no question
was the Box sealed and he was like it
was a piece of red tape yes or no it's
it was a box sealed and he's like I
don't understand it's like dude this
really frustrated me clay the answer is
no the box is not sealed they're playing
a semantic game they're arguing the
colloquial definition in a legal context
don't take the bait if you come to me
and say they could have wrapped that box
with Saran Wrap was the Box sealed no
but wasn't it Serrato with Saran Wrap
well that's not a legal seal so no it
wasn't sealed they're trying to trick
you because to the average person taping
something shut is sealing it shut right
that's the manipulation they kept doing
I was it's so frustrating they're gonna
show just those three seconds on the
local news and then that's what you're
parents are going to believe and that's
it and what they do is they're going to
show that clip then they're going to
give false contact context saying
despite acknowledging the boxes were
sealed the you know Carrie Lakes witness
refused to acknowledge to the court that
it was sealed they cut out the part
where he said they have tamper evidence
seals that they put on boxes that you
can't remove without evidence of
tampering they did not have that
they were also like the defense team was
just I don't want to say they were
scrambling but it was obviously they had
a different strategy like it was like a
we're going to be forceful in trying to
discredit these people as quick as
possible right where there's like
they're set up with Nuance clearly with
the plaintiffs and then they just get
you know like a hatchet to the Head
after that and uh I'm like
it was they were so condescending this
might be just too personal but I
couldn't sit next to these people I was
sitting next to the defense team most of
the time they're just laughing like all
all these different times like the
attorney would talk like they just it
was like a very condescending thing like
let's have a little decorum here for
people you know like it's like when
someone mispronounces a word and someone
laughs at it it's like there's no point
to that to me it's like you're just like
just being rude for the sake of being
rude
um and they also have like just a giant
team it's like it's like when you look
at a pop song and there's like 30 people
wrote it and you look at the other like
a rock song there's like two people who
wrote it that's why I felt like I was up
against in this uh small courtroom in
order to bring the truth or at least
transparency on this do you just find it
was it was on video was this was this
court case I'm watching live you find
like specific little Clips cut them out
put them on Twitter make them go viral
that is that is that the way to move
forward let me let me let me maybe I
just wanna I just wanna stress okay you
know I I I don't want to talk about you
Oliver Darcy but we're gonna talk about
you he tweeted out and there was another
journalist who did he was like Donnie
O'Sullivan of CNN may have had a
suspension lifted but he can't come back
on Twitter unless he deletes the tweet
and it's just everybody's everybody you
know in the anti-establishment anti-woke
was like yo did the lead media reporter
for CNN just learn right now how getting
banned getting suspended on Twitter
Works another journalist tweeted this
today saying Daniel Sullivan remains
locked out they're telling him he must
delete a tweet and I'm like is this how
it's been for like a decade and they
don't know this so the challenge is
you've got a combination of ineptitude
and willful manipulation from the from
the corporate press when Carrie we're on
stage at America fest with TP USA and
Charlie Kirk goes we just got breaking
news Carrie Lakes election challenge is
going to trial the whole crowd goes wow
they're all screaming and cheering then
I Then I then I'm like I got a fact I
gotta I gotta pull this up I pull up the
story from the local Fox Outlet it says
judge dismisses most of Carrie Lake's
lawsuit and I'm like what but she's
going to trial why isn't that the
headline that's huge they got past a
motion to dismiss
again I'm just gonna say I'm pessimistic
the way I'm hearing this judge you know
he's like
it does seem like he's getting
frustrated with the defense attorneys as
well but I'm just kind of like I think
this dude is acting like you know I'm
giving them a fair chance and then he's
gonna he's gonna come back and say well
you didn't prove there was any intent
therefore you're gone that's how I feel
there he's offering leniency in places
where I didn't think he'd give leniency
like the plaintiffs aren't perfect like
they've definitely like screwed up a few
things here and there and a little
forgetful he that one guy is like like
Big Lebowski in a suit I enjoy watching
him because he just has funny phrases
yeah I like him um but you know I don't
think either side is fully prepared just
because they had like such a short
notice so you can see like there's a lot
of scrambling and discombobulation
behind the scenes you probably see a lot
of it on the live stream as well but yep
but yeah they they couldn't upload the
the voicemail recording and so the judge
was like we're not gonna play it and
it's like how are we supposed to get you
this file in like a day you know what I
mean yeah yeah it's a mess
probably I think people stay positive
and optimistic about it because that'll
generate the you know the energy needed
to continue to post clips about it and
to spread them around
you know what's funny though I talked to
a lot since I was there so early I was
talking to just like people who work
there who literally aren't engaged in
politics at all and just asking them
what they thought and they're most of
them are so disengaged from it all
together they just I don't want to say
they're like uh they've given up they
just don't care and it's like in their
very workplace you know it's like yeah
whatever that's crazy and I'm also a lot
of these judges so many are just so far
removed from everything and to an extent
they're supposed to be the judge is
supposed to be like okay present to me
the facts and then we'll go through it
yeah but what I'm what I think we end up
seeing with so many judges and not just
this case but basically across the board
with everything is they're thinking to
themselves look I don't know anything
about this stuff I don't want to be
involved in this stuff this case is so
political everyone's gonna get mad at me
I'm just gonna tell them no one get out
of my courtroom and so they end up just
saying get out get out don't care don't
want to deal with it yeah that's a weak
judge then and that's too many of them
yeah based on what I've heard already
in this testimony I will I will say a
few things a witness saying there is no
chain of custody is not definitive proof
there is no chain of custody it is a
statement of fact sworn under oath and
now there must be the courts must seek
to confirm was chain of custody broken
that is an illegal action
if if the person tasked with with
maintaining chain of custody willfully
did not do that
then you've got intent and what they're
arguing though is uh what people have
called it is non-feasance as opposed to
malfeasance I if I was a judge I'd be
like get out of my face if you're a
barista at my coffee shop
and you walk in wearing your uniform and
I say you're going to stand here at the
register when that person hands you a 10
bill you will punch in their order put
the money in the register give them
their change and they go you got it then
the person walks up and they go I'm not
doing that that is an intentional act to
defy so if you have a a election
official and they are legally told
you're going to be here okay I'm
standing here okay now you're going to
count the ballots okay I'm gonna count
the bouts you're gonna felt this form
okay I'm gonna fill out the form okay
now do it no they intentionally chose to
break the law
based on that will the judge agree I
don't know so in my opinion
I don't know exactly how you Rectify
this because if you've got a witness
saying chain of custody was broken on
nearly 300 000 ballots that that of
course goes over the margin of Victory
with seventeen thousand and then you had
the last witness they tried getting him
they said do you have evidence that uh
the you know the vote would have uh if
if these errors if the tabulators didn't
break the election outcome would be
different dude actually said the margin
of victory was 17 000 votes I am
convinced that if the machine's working
properly Carrie Lake would be Governor
they didn't like that no they didn't
Kyle are you getting any flashbacks to
your court proceedings you know I mean
you look at this and then you look at
how these people like
you can just grab the mic yeah might as
well hold it yeah that's a good look you
you look back and then you look how they
tried to they try to get them to go down
these rabbit holes and then they asked
them these like I'm gonna say it leading
questions I think they I think they are
leading questions because
they know where they're gonna get you
yeah yeah and they don't have any they
aren't preparing them and they they
freak out they freeze they're like how
am I gonna answer this what if I say
this what if I say no they are not
putting they are not stealing it because
like with your example with the Saran
Wrap whatever right say no it was not
sealed but then they say what about the
Saran Wrap what about this wasn't there
that on it they're scared if they say no
they're gonna think people are gonna
think they're stupid because they're
like well it was wrapped up so when when
you're we're all I think everybody glued
to that Court proceeding with you and I
felt like there were several times they
tried to get you and you didn't let them
get you I mean did you did you did you
get uh practice did you uh in like
Envision or or were kind of trained with
the questions that they were giving you
there was a couple questions out there
that I didn't prepare for but we did go
through a mock trial uh Dr John
Demetrius she was my jury consultant and
she helped choose my jury and then she
helped set up the mock trials and
that's how we determined if I was
actually going to testify because uh two
of the two of the three panels heard me
testify and the two that heard me
testify found me not guilty and then the
one that didn't hear me testify
um they did they had a mistrial did you
did you testify from the beginning yeah
I wanted to tell my story I had nothing
to hide yeah you were super authentic to
me like he came off a very authentic I I
did nothing wrong I had the truth on my
side and I thought I wanted to tell my
story it came out it came off that way I
think probably to most of us yeah and
then you got a really great meme where
you're pouring gas and crying you saw
that I think you posted that yeah I put
it on a t-shirt
what was the what was the meme I maybe I
should just see the picture
so Kyle basically recounting the story
has an emotional you know recurrence and
uh
when gas prices went through the roof
did you make that or did someone else
make this meme basically it's
Kyle basically you're starting to cry
you know you're holding the gas pump in
front of a car like the gas prices got
you I think somebody else made that Meme
um it's actually really funny because
the left has used that Meme against me
so many times they've made fun of me or
so I just took it and I owned it
I'm not gonna let you guys use my my
face and make fun of me for it so I'm
gonna make fun of myself that's how you
do it that's humility I'm sorry no no
have you talked to Binger at all I have
not talked to fluffer boy at all
nice no I was gonna say we were just
talking about with the Kerry Lake trial
how the media is falsely framing
everything that had to be I mean did did
you know the media was always lying
about stuff before this happened but and
and I have to imagine as you're going
through the court proceedings even
before it reading the media was like
just fiction just pure fiction I mean
you see the things the media are saying
they twist things they use sound bites
and like it's ridiculous they try to get
away with it and in some instance they
do I mean they called me a white
supremacist a murderer vigilante and
none of those are true but with the
Kerry Lake situation they're only saying
parts that they want to say and they're
leaving stuff out they're not they're
not telling the full story and I think
they should be obligated to as as the
media to report people on the facts
forgive me if this is too personal but
like were there people that were close
to you that started seeing you
differently because they were believing
the news instead of you I mean I've lost
a lot of friends and a lot of family
members because because they they didn't
want to fall out of like the Click or
their friend groups unbelievable but you
know that's okay because it really shows
who people are as humans and now I have
better people surrounding me yeah that's
the positive way to look at that I
hopefully it's like a curse But like
everyone gets to go through that in
their life where they shed the skin of
their past with the kids you grew up
with and the parents that you don't like
or don't get along with if you don't you
know maybe you still do but those people
you know when they start to disagree
with you and complain about your new who
you've you're not who you used to be
that's okay because you're growing and
changing as a person I just hope it
doesn't callus any of us because I've
been thinking about that myself after
the last two years they weren't as wild
as what you went through but like a lot
of us have experienced that in the last
few years 10 years and uh I sometimes
I'm like worried like I don't want to be
too callous and not extend that
forgiveness to someone else who in the
future maybe I should still extend that
sometimes it comes full circle like
you'll go through a phase where you fall
out with people for whatever 20 years
and then if you you know you stay true
to yourself it's inevitably that you
can't you can't deny that reality you
know transparent current reality when
someone's really who they are that's I
think it's a parent my view on this is
that I think some people are inherently
evil and it's true for sure it's it's I
obviously you can look at child
exploitation and stuff and just know
that there are truly depraved people you
can look at I think it was maybe it may
have been Dahmer or Bundy where they
they sat on court like yeah I know what
I was doing was evil and wrong and all
that stuff and I deserve to be in prison
or whatever yeah so like they know what
they're doing yeah but then you look at
there are some people like in my life
and I'm wondering if you if I assume you
probably experienced something like this
people who you thought were really good
friends of yours because the way the the
media decided the story is going just
everything about your friendship
everything you've ever experienced is
meaningless and you are now enemies I've
experienced that personally with people
I've known for my past some of these
people where the last thing I ever said
to them was we had a Skate Session we
drank some some smoothies and I was like
bro fist bump Let's Skate next time I'll
see you later and then you know you
don't realize it but it's the last time
you ever hung out but you leave on good
terms and then a few years later they're
on Twitter lying about you smearing you
and attacking you and I'm like you never
knew how evil that person was until they
decided they could profit off of their
knowledge of you or or the fact that you
were friends
has something like that happened to you
yeah I've seen that a lot of times
especially with people I've gone to
school with uh in the beginning I was
seeing some articles that they were like
oh Kyle Rittenhouse was this like
terrible person who was like violent in
school and I was just like I wasn't
violent in school I dropped out freshman
year I wasn't a senior with you in high
school I did I since then did graduate
but I'm like I was in school with you
for like a year you you don't know who I
am I also dropped out freshman year yeah
back at you now yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're writing they're writing smears
and and like this is a big point of
attack for the left like not going
through institutionalized learning
facilities is like they Point At You and
do that thing from Body Snatchers
oh yeah like and then they they say haha
that proves you're stupid and I'm like I
don't know I'm just running a business
man that's oh I'm sorry that's I'll just
say that's how I felt watching a lot of
these defense attorneys today like
almost like laughing at the guy with the
accent like like a they couldn't even
help it you know like the Alabama guy
yeah right like it was just like today
was like kind of like a joke you know
not all of them but like a few of them
and uh you know earlier they were just
some of them were joking about like what
private schools they went to you know
they're from a different dimension than
me and uh you could see that in the way
they treat other people what if they
really are from a different dimension I
think two two universes collided and
that's why we have the culture War at
least
inter-dimensional demons is what some
people call it yo you said you dropped
out but then did you go back to school I
I ended up while I was on trial I did
online school and I ended up getting my
high school diploma the left will attack
people that don't have an education but
they will be some of the most successful
business owners out there yet the person
who has is like 110 000 in debt because
they wanted to get their doctorate
degree or however much it costs gender
studies yeah they're uh lesbian dance
Theory that's right right yeah
um I would study that that's just yeah
come on think about it if you if you
were going to study feminist dance
Theory under James Lindsay
that's worth spending money on because
he's not gonna he's not trying to
indoctrinate he's actually breaking down
what they're doing and why they're doing
it is he dancing we're not talking about
feminists Kyle's saying something else
but what I'm saying I'm saying like woke
ideology as a whole not just like one
subset of like lesbian dance Theory I'm
saying if you if you actually took a
study on wokeness and critical race
Theory from James Lindsay he'd give you
a holistic view of what their goals are
what they believe but when you go to the
average college they're actually just
indoctrinating and telling you you know
white people are bad or something like
that yeah and then those people that
graduate end up living off of welfare
and end up doing it nothing with their
lives and living off the government
essentially makes sense yeah I was on
welfare for a while unemployment and
then it was hard to get off because
there was like if you get a job you lose
your unemployment I'm like well make
less money out of my poverty cycle it's
like okay so you're in that cycle and
then you're getting money for the
government then you go out and work and
then you're making less than the
government's giving you and you're like
oh well I can I can go afford this fancy
steak right now but when I'm working I'm
living off of McDonald's because I can't
afford that fancy steak and I had more
free time too on unemployment it was
crazy like you could like they don't
want to do anything to contribute to
society and
what is this maybe like seven 15 years
ago I was on unemployment after losing a
job and they make you call once a week
and you know it was in Illinois in
Chicago and you got to answer questions
like did you look for work yes you know
did you make any money no and um after a
few months was this during covid no no
no this is 15 years ago 22 years ago no
no sorry 15. and um I'm talking to this
woman
and she was like okay you know your your
unemployment is up for review or
whatever she said have you been looking
for work and I said I have and she's
like have you found anything and I was
like I'll be honest with you like there
are some jobs I could take probably
because like I'm not trying to be on
unemployment but they pay less than I
was making before and I'm kind of
worried and just no no no no don't take
those jobs she's like the last thing we
want is for you to take a job that pays
less then you find out you can't pay
your bills you lose your job and you're
back on unemployment again and I was
like oh that actually kind of makes
sense she goes you need to find
something comparable so that you can get
back in the flow of things
I think that makes sense but I also
think some people are going to be like
look if you're if you find a job then
you're getting paid you know 50k a year
and then you lose your job going
unemployment then they tell you that
you're never going to get off
unemployment until it's at least until
it expires yeah it's like coven was
beautiful for a lot of people we got
that covered cash the bonus yeah they're
getting free they were getting
unemployment plus the bonus and it was
extended for a year and people were just
not working and that money that they
were getting people think this is like
your tax dollars no no that's modern
monetary Theory they're basically just
extracting the value of your money
that's why inflation is going through
yeah one of the reasons and a nice
Donald Trump two thousand dollar check
that the government couldn't even roll
out correctly everyone was really happy
about that speaking of what's this 1.7
trillion dollar Omnibus Bill I don't
know if we're gonna is that for us we're
gonna yeah that's actually for you it's
for the world actually let's uh let's
pull this story up we got this here from
Fox News Kevin McCarthy breaks with
McConnell will oppose 1.7 trillion
dollar Omnibus Bill McConnell
Republicans have voted to support the
bill so we have Jake Sherman tweeting
GOP leader Kevin McCarthy will attend
the Senate up steering lunch today to
make the case against the Omnibus 20
Republicans voted to proceed to the bill
yesterday and the Senate GOP leadership
is supporting the package
I gotta say look I'm not I'm not the
biggest fan of McCarthy people have been
complaining that he was funding he was
putting up money to stop populist
candidates but clearly the pressure
campaign on his speakership is making
him at least move away this Omnibus is
completely under garbage for one reason
now I know Rand Paul came out in his an
epic viral video where he was just
ripping it apart I could only say this
because I was because I was watching the
Kerry Lake trial I didn't get a whole
lot of it the only thing I did
understand was that Rand Paul called it
he said outright it's going to be the
18th or 19th we're gonna get a 5 000
page spending bill that we're not going
to be allowed to read and then they're
going to expect us to sign it and this
is what they're doing right now
apparently there's funding for corporate
media in this I've been seeing people
talk about there's a whole bunch of
garbage it's 1.7 trillion
it's a total Destruction of the American
dollar it's spending money that they
don't have on crazy issues and things
that absolutely make no sense at all I
looked in some of the details here it
looks like there's going to be money
allocated from your money from American
taxes or just devaluing your money to
secure the border of Pakistan and
Lebanon in order to have recruitment for
women in police forces in South and
Central America gender programs in
Pakistan and there's also an allocation
for 2.6 billion dollars in order to fund
the prosecution of the January 6th
domestic terrorists according to CNN
that's their reporting of it but but
again this is only what what we're
seeing now no one still hasn't really
read the full list as of course it's
4155 Pages some of the worst people in
politics have gotten together and said
you know what we're just going to write
ourselves a blank check you can't even
read what's in there this should be
absolutely criminal and they're going to
add absolutely tanked the US economy and
spend money on on gender programs in
Pakistan this is absolutely bewildering
this is out of touch with reality and if
there ever was a conspiracy theory that
came true about the great reset and
destroying the American way of life in
the American middle class this is the
perfect example I just did some math the
U.S debt right now is 31 trillion so if
we're going to print another 1.7 that's
1 18th of our national debt that means
that we're devaluing the Dollar by 1 18.
of its own value which is like four
cents your dollar is not going to be
worth after if this goes through your
dollar's worth 96 cents that's all fake
dude you're a dollar worth 96 cents but
if you go back to pre-jacko Island your
dollar's worth like point zero zero one
cent right when you start to do the math
you see the compounding diminishment of
the value at the purchase and power of
the US dollar keeps going down
dramatically almost every few years and
when you look at it from even the 1960s
it is an absolute debasement it is an
absolute destruction I mean we are
reaching levels of Myanmar Germany we
are reaching levels of what people saw
in Zimbabwe of what people saw in
Venezuela there's no going back from
this this is Banks just printing zero on
the computer just clicking zero zero
zero zero zero zero giving it to all
their buddies all their friends this is
the sinking ship and this is them taking
all the silver out of the ship and
making sure that they're able to have it
for themselves I feel like there's
people are trying to sync the ship so we
could remove the ballast I agree there's
no going back there's no paying off the
debt but we could default on the debt
very good point they blew up the ship
now they're taking the silver from the
ship and now they're they're on their
life but that's what I've been saying
it's like the Titanic hits the iceberg
and instead of telling the people on the
ship they're running and grabbing as
much silver and stuff in their pockets
as they make their way to the the
lifeboats and the memers are playing the
music and that's right enjoying some
kind of semblance of reality we know
it's happening and we're standing there
just rocking out like oh we're going
down but uh I guess my question is then
we're watching this happen with this
Omnibus spending bill what do you do if
let me tell you a story there was this
viral viral story a few months ago where
it was like these people inherited a
house from their grandfather and then
they popped open one of the floorboards
in the attic and they found a case with
like fifty thousand dollars in it and
they were like this is amazing and it
was fifty thousand dollars from like the
1950s and I was like bro that was like a
million bucks back then so if they're if
their grandfather bought gold or some
other hard asset and hid that instead of
US Dollars they'd be millionaires and
what's happening is the people with a
lot of money are buying gold and hard
assets because there's no real estate as
well exactly I've never done the
property that they would have now and
the people that aren't able to afford
hard assets right now are the ones that
are at the bottom of the Ponzi scheme I
don't know how to help them other than
like if we did default to the National
the Federal Reserve very least we say
we're not paying you back the interest
on our debt which would probably cut 15
trillion I don't know how much of the of
the debt is interest but if we were to
say we're not paying any of it back
Private Bank you've been screwing us for
100 years it's over uh the it would
Bannon and Steve Bannon asked him on
stage in America Fest the other night if
that would be ethical and he said yeah I
said would it destroy our our standing
around the world and you know but I mean
it was that was vague it wasn't we
weren't specific getting into it I need
to get more economists involved with
what would actually happen to the the
U.S the new currency if we were to but
he said if we don't force debt
sovereignty a sovereign debt collapse
that it's going to happen to us against
our will in a way that we don't want so
we may as well take it by the horns and
make it happen from from my perspective
we are seeing the deliberate destruction
of the American Petro dollar we have
seen Saudi Arabia position themselves
closer and closer to China uh
establishing more relations with them we
just saw the Indian Central Bank had
come out and warning that it was
cryptocurrencies that allegedly could
trigger the next financial crisis what
we saw with Sam bankman freed what we
saw with him moving around billions of
dollars from the bank of Ukraine working
with the world economic Forum working
with of course American politicians
funneling all that money there I think
we have a perfect scapegoat that will be
Bitcoin that will be cryptocurrencies
that will be decentralized currencies
that will be taken down by these Central
Bankers that will then introduce the
Central Bank digital currency and with
that to social credit score this is a
long game that they've been after for a
very long time and they will stop at
nothing at trying to achieve that this
is the current reality that we're
dealing with and I think the more we
wake up to it the more we realize it the
more we could actually try to stop it
but right now when these big Central
Bankers are are causing so much damage
what can we really do that's the big
question that I think a lot of people
should be asking themselves right now
this feels like the perfect story for
for Ian and Luke who are ragging on the
fed the whole time I just don't know if
Kyle has any thoughts on like Financial
policy or anything like that but you
know what do you think man I'm 19.
so what kind of stocks and bonds do you
have what's your retirement Kyle please
tell us Kyle crypto what Bitcoin are you
in what crypto are you sorry I'm just
bust I'm just I you know I tried crypto
I tried crypto for a little bit I don't
really understand it at all I will be
completely honest I honestly am so lost
in the conversation
um I was too in crypto but that's why I
asked I'm like it's like Luke and Ian
just go back and forth we could keep
going meaning could keep ranting also
just one last caveat here Sam Bank me
freed by the way will likely be moved to
the same prison that Jeffrey Epstein was
uh taken out of so the story is going to
become hidden Circle very soon no that's
not the joke yes those are the reports
coming in right now as he's being
extradited to the United States as we're
speaking right now but but Kyle just
more in general to kind of ask you here
to to put to bring you in with this
conversation financially what are you
seeing from your perspective you're 19
years old you're still young but you
know what what are you seeing with uh
savings money how people are are
treating their money are people people
going out and partying and going crazy
with their money or are they saying hey
times are really tough
you know some people I know like I know
a lot of kids my age I live in a college
town and I see a lot of people that just
go out and party I stay at home I'm
facing a civil lawsuit right now I
really don't have the money to go out
and do all these things that people my
age are I dipped into a cryptocurrency a
little bit I don't understand it I
bought a coin I made like 80 bucks off
of it yeah there you go the market
crashed and I was like oh this is going
down and I was using coin by base I said
I was going down why no oh no no okay
sorry go ahead we'll talk after yeah FTX
right Luke no
centralized exchanges hold your own Keys
People For Goodness Gracious please
goodness I'm sorry go ahead Bill almond
suggested that when you use the uh the
networks like big like coinbase and
binance that you treat them like public
restrooms you go in do your business you
make your trade and then you put it back
on your own that's a good analysis
public restrooms yeah you don't want to
hang out there and see what gets smeared
on very bad people very very bad
politicians hang on in public restrooms
and they do very bad things that they
were as they were previously caught
doing before but I won't get into that
story sorry
you were saying Kylie
but uh you know I pulled out
um I collected my 80 bucks I made from
it and
you gotta pay taxes on that now oh 15
yeah I got to pay taxes 15 to 30 I did
not know that yes well it's still like
crazy the tax law and the crypto because
no one knows what's happening like it
all of a sudden they talk about
inflation 31 trillion in US Dollars how
about the inflation the crypto inflation
that just happened over the last 10
years what's the real Global Currency
number right now they say the market cap
of crypto is only 2 trillion but I mean
you know it just feels like the whole
machine about to explode okay with the
Twitter files we've got so much coming
out Twitter files eight the FBI I think
it was the FBI right or who was a
military intelligence engaging in
psychological operations pretending to
be middle easterners we we've actually
known this story going back to I think
it was 2011 or 2012 with uh it was um I
think it was Barrett Brown who did uh
what was the name of their project PM I
think it was and they exposed that U.S
military was were buying sock puppet
accounts fake accounts to do
psychological operations we now have new
uh developments from Twitter the fact
that we know that and it came because
Elon Musk bought Twitter it feels like
the whole facade is crumbling you look
at how they're spending money we're off
the fractional Reserve banking policy
we're on to infinite Reserve Banks can
just make whatever amount of money they
want give it to whoever they want the
system is just gutted and it feels like
they know it everything's about to
collapse my question I guess is is it
intentional you know I think you were
who was just saying Ian were you saying
that like if like it's not doing it on
purpose if they weren't trying to
destroy the economy and Rob the middle
class of their wealth what would they be
doing differently I think that's the
question that a lot of people need to
ask themselves let's jump to this story
from EV magazine we have to do this
evmagazine.com Sam bankman freed likely
to be transferred to the same jail where
Jeffrey Epstein allegedly committed
suicide not kill himself I love how EV
magazine actually put allegedly like
they're not gonna just say it despite
the fact the official narrative from all
of the corporate press and everything is
that Epstein did they're they're still
maintaining allegedly so uh Sam bankman
freed you know run an FTX into the
ground and uh gets arrested and now
they're like well you know we're going
to transfer him to jail and then I have
to imagine
the moment he found out they're like oh
they're transferring you to uh this is
the prison he just I started welling up
because he knows what's coming next have
you been following this at all Kyle
you know uh kind of putting me on the
spot right here uh no no that's nuts
it's like the biggest Financial scam in
human history one of if not the most the
biggest I think I'm gonna have to start
learning some more about it well yeah
but you know we don't need to put you on
the spot yeah
when Luke brought up that the jail
Epstein was in and then you know he was
shuffled off this moral core mortal coil
and now it's imagine his face Sam
bankman freed you saw like the video of
him like running down the street scared
because people saw him yeah this is an
absolutely corrupted jail where the jail
guards still weren't held responsible
for their larger crimes of whatever
happened I mean I'm trying to be careful
with the words that I'm trying to use
here when I'll just say when Epstein was
taken out I think that's more of a fair
assessment uh since there was multiple
attempts multiple camera failures
multiple failures of security multiple
procedures that were not followed uh the
the two prison guards that were looking
on their phone for high ticket items
that they were going to purchase like
motorcycles and expensive furniture they
were of course uh you know brought to
court under federal charges the federal
government uh essentially gave them a
slap on the wrist they never faced any
kind of real repercussion for it and for
that person Sam Beckman free to go to
that jail as he was arrested right
before he was about to give testimony to
Congress really shows you that there
might be something bigger here as many
people question where did he get a lot
of that money from where did all that
money come from as a lot of people are
also saying as soon as Epstein kind of
was removed from the picture there was a
lot of money in play there was still a
lot of assets and money from Jeffrey
Epstein that still hasn't been accounted
for a lot of people are speculating that
that money was moved into SPF in order
to continue the money laundering
operation involving the world economic
Forum the bank of Ukraine and that's how
they were kind of moving money back and
forth through all these Sinister parties
some someone said on the show they said
that when when when the Epstein stuff
happened like right afterwards
everything started unraveling covet Co I
mean everything everything like the
world started to fall apart after that
so I felt well people's consensus people
people's understanding of the world and
participation with it kind of faltered a
little bit because how else could they
not realize that that your tax dollars
were paying for this international
trafficking and extortion operation of
children the people on the left admitted
it the people on the right admitted it
we all agree that this was happening the
corporate media is still lying about it
but the only thing that kept it alive
was a hashtag Jeffrey Epstein didn't
kill himself
for a little bit there exactly what if
the story is Epstein gets recruited to
handle kind of like this International
laundering but then secretly begins this
blackmail operation and turns it on his
handlers and these Global Elites so that
when they're like all right Jeffrey
you're gonna do this and do that and
then he walks in there and goes actually
smoking cigar or not and then he presses
Planet TV and it shows some like lewd
and lascivious video of a world leader
because that's the theory right that he
was recording these people on the island
and they're like what is this he's like
you're going to do what I want now
what's the possibility that he was
either a patsy or that he was actually
running the show what do you think Luke
it's uh I mean he was one of the players
but he was one of the Disposable players
he was still taking orders obviously
since they took him out but he did have
surveillance cameras hooked up
everywhere in every room especially in
his New York City Mansion there was many
um there was a lot of testimony people
coming forward saying there was cameras
in the bathroom there was cameras in the
hallways there was hidden cameras
everywhere and one of the victims
recently came forward and said Jeffrey
Epstein was very smart when politicians
and powerful people were forcing
themselves onto children he made sure he
wasn't in those uh camera angles and he
made sure that the video footage was
kept in a safe the FBI broke that safe
and then they found a whole bunch of
photos and videos that we still haven't
heard about today doesn't that suggest
he wasn't the pawn that he was the
ringleader I don't know
um we don't know at the end of the day
because we're still scratching the
surface of what we actually know that's
happening here he was a major player
he's one he was one of the biggest
players but he was again a disposable
player that at the end of the day I
think Steve was taking orders I don't
trigger people above him I don't know
though but then he made it to the other
side of the chessboard and thought he
was a queen that's what I'm saying he
flipped it on him because as we were
pointing out like the moment he's gone
every all of this stuff starts
unraveling we start seeing people get
exposed the money starts going wild like
you make a good point maybe it's very
speculative but then FTX starts
funneling this money and now sbf's going
to the same place I wonder if he wasn't
a pawn he was like a centerpiece a
linchpin connecting the dots of all
these things without him the whole thing
just unravels there's a painting by
Maria farmer who was one of the girls
that was trafficked or like victims I
guess if you want to call or survivors
of this whole experience and uh it shows
she like paints all the people that she
remembers being at the island and being
involved at you know Epstein's house in
New York and stuff like that and Jeff is
in the picture in the far right upper
right corner we can probably find the
picture at some points called the
sceptiles or the setios SCT Iles and it
shows Jeffrey in a UFO up like he's like
a he was the space cadet he was the
crazy wild face of the a piece of the
movement cult leader but she certainly
did not peg him as the center of
anything if anything it was giland
Maxwell in the very center of this
picture's Guillain Maxwell the head of a
serpent like the head of a dragon and uh
then you there's lots of other faces of
the daughter of Robert Maxwell who also
was someone who was deemed a double
agent working with uh Israeli Mossad
Russian intelligence UK intelligence as
well uh a lot of people call them a
double agent and that's why he was kind
of taken out he went on a boat ride and
then was never kind of found again he
was essentially a Rupert Murdoch kind of
figure in the media Glenn Maxwell also
is another kind of fascinating figure
that played a very key Central role here
uh she also very interestingly also had
uh a helicopter license uh submarine
license as well and yeah she was wasn't
galane in charge of like going to the
boat and getting on the files away from
people after he like disappeared
appeared or died what do you mean like
the galane like there's other sisters
and like she was the one that went and
got the files like from the business to
keep it safe I don't you gotta you gotta
uh that's I think me reference some of
that but her sisters are also connected
to the FBI and their database centers
and also to Big Tech social media as
well so it's a big club and uh we're not
in I've been listening to Whitney Webb
interviews about this yeah what new web
does some great great you got to give me
a specific reference yeah like it was
doing that timeline was but it made it
seem like she was just like I think
Whitney's point was that Elaine was way
more entrenched with whatever dealings
her dad was doing because she was
um there to collect certain files at the
uh I think after he died but I gotta
check that I got that painting that uh
that Ian referenced yeah and it is it is
crazy yeah it is crazy I mean can we
pull it up it's of course anecdotal uh
this is from Maria Farmer's memory of
what she experienced while she was this
is Lane right here right in the middle
there's Bezos she's in a bubble like
she's protected oh she's got like a drag
dragon body with a weird deal or
whatever is this Basil's right here what
does that say is that that looks like
baby no you can start naming names I
don't know if my life is on the line if
I do that but all their faces are right
there for you to look at a name yourself
if you want to this guy they're right in
the middle who's that guy that's Lex
westner oh he's the head of uh uh Bed
Bath and Beyond and and Victoria's
Secret yeah look at this look at this
guy on the TV that's like Bill Clinton
this is nuts this look this one here
looks very suggestive it's like a fever
is that hanging in the White House can
you see in the upper right there's
Jeffrey Epstein in a UFO no in the very
upper yeah yeah in the very upper right
in that gray UFO are you sure look at a
delay that's Jeff these weird people
this is a weird painting anyway it kind
of reminds me of that old painting of
like the guy reaching through the
dimensions
you seen that no what is that old like
carving I heard what they call it but
he's like reaching through this
Dimension to another Dimensions Kyle
were you in the Matrix or outside of the
Matrix when this story broke Kyle uh
were you in the Matrix or outside the
Matrix when this larger story broke uh
by the by The Matrix do you mean in jail
or yeah yeah or like like as far as like
you were awakened to what's really
happening politically or before
everything happened when you weren't
politically involved when the story
broke I was uh I was not in the Matrix
okay I was wondering what your response
was if you heard this or even if it was
being talked about especially amongst
the the young group of people that you
were hanging out with no no this was not
a conversation piece I'm sitting here
looking at that photograph and I'm just
like wow this is one of this is one of
the most creepiest like photos I've seen
ever it's just like it's just weird and
interesting yeah when you agreed to come
on the show it was like getting pushed
right into the deep end of the pool you
know what I mean it's like you've got
your story we've got stuff to talk about
and then like Luke's just we could go
further down the rabbit hole by the way
we're just starting we're just kind of
digging the you know we're just kind of
Tucker Carlson just last week he uh he
basically reported that the CIA killed
JFK yeah or that they were involved in
it yeah so it's like that I see that all
over the place today huh that's great no
one's talking about that really I just
it's it's strange for me you know I'm
sure for everybody listening that when
we're younger it's like look there's no
Global Elite ring of like trafficking
going on the CIA was not involved as a
conspiracy theories and now I'm looking
at my phone and I'm like what time is it
how much longer until they come out and
claim the moon landing wasn't actually a
real thing like they're just gonna like
Chuck across is gonna come out and be
like we've got new evidence that
actually it was by 5 p.m tonight yeah oh
they're breaking here yeah the
conspiracy theories are coming true yeah
what you've inherited like the the
shattered simulation speaking of Joe
conspiracy theories did you see what uh
the FBI released on the statement about
the Twitter files today oh yeah man yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's uh let's let's pull
this up I have a suite from Carl
Benjamin because he had a great one so
we have the statement from the FBI on
Twitter they say breaking uh the FBI
responds to the Twitter files claiming
that their own leaked Communications
with Twitter are misinformation to
discredit the agency they said it is
unfortunate that conspiracy theorists
and others are feeding the American
public misinformation with the sole
purpose of attempting to discredit the
agency Carl Benjamin of the Lotus Eaters
podcast says oh I forgot that I was just
a conspiracy theorist and the FBI didn't
collude with Twitter to suppress the New
York Post Center Biden laptop story that
I watched happen in real time and then
read the files which show them
discussing it My Lying Eyes keep
deceiving me this is this is real life
okay it's it's unraveling we know they
did it we know they're doing it we have
the proof they did it and they're just
coming out and lying saying they didn't
do it it's buzzwords misinformation
conspiracy these buzzwords I'm kind of
getting fed up with these buzzwords the
buzzwords that's what they do they they
throw in these words this misinformation
these conspiracy theorists
just to try to cover their own asses and
not not do anything about it because
they know they're wrong and they know
they're in the wrong but but I love how
uh Luke often brings us up too that
conspiracy theorist was a phrase created
I think Tucker talked about this that
the phrase first emerged in the
corporate media around was it JFK JFK
yep and now the FBI is is using it to
discredit legitimate emails from Twitter
leaked by the CEO of Twitter to a
variety of reporters showing the FBI not
only were they instructing or giving
guidance on who to censor but they were
paying for it my favorite component of
the story is that uh you know we're
going to mention him again Oliver Darcy
the media reporter for CNN reported no
the FBI didn't pay Twitter for
censorship what they were doing was
reimbursing Twitter for the for the
labor costs of that's so nice fulfilling
government requests I'm like this is
what I talk about when they're sitting
there and you're like
um you know Mr FB agent is there a door
on the front of the building or no know
Twitter's a better uh Mr Dorsey does the
Twitter headquarters have a door oh no
it doesn't there's no door no there
isn't how do you get in there's a portal
that's that's the game they play so this
is what they're doing right now no the
FBI didn't pay Twitter they reimbursed
them for the labor costs of acquiescing
two government requests
so they paid them they gave them money
this is the perfect way to understand
that uh almost everyone is in an abusive
relationship with their government this
is the perfect example of gaslighting uh
double speak 1984 bull crap that they're
just putting out there and what what do
they think they're going to achieve here
I mean obviously more and more people
are seeing the Twitter files they're
seeing the documents they're seeing the
evidence for themselves they're
listening to it they're they're seeing
it with their own eyes and right now the
state is telling you don't believe your
own eyes don't believe your own ears
don't believe your own mind believe us
that's the level we are at when it comes
to the propaganda that we're dealing
with that's a very dangerous level for
any state it's political Amber Heard
like I gotta remember she's like she's
like I didn't punch you I just closed my
fist and hit you like what Kyle after
you've experienced with the Kenosha
experience something that it probably
less than you know one trillionth of
percent of humans have experienced stuff
like that or very very few Americans
experience what was your like what's
your perception of the government before
and after and weren't the feds lying and
keeping data away from your current
trial let's talk about that for a second
though so the FBI they had aerial Drone
footage filming my trial film not my
tryout they probably were doing that too
but the event that you were involved in
my uh the incident that happened they
were filming it with a
um with the aerial plane and they had
thermal imaging I don't know if you
remember that and they gave us a like we
we knew it was out there they refused
they had a they had a guy come in that
was operating the camera sorry I'm just
trying to remember this correctly he was
operating the camera and then he was
testifying my attorney asked him what's
the tail number on the plane because we
had it and then the state's attorney
comes up nope we're objecting like
here's his Tui letter like pulled him
off they refused to air it I don't know
if they aired it they refused to error
it to my belief they didn't want him to
have his name out there and he couldn't
be on camera and I was like what what is
the government doing what is the FBI his
whole testimony was thrown out the judge
was like okay the jury has to like they
can't use anything he said
and we didn't they also had a drone
video and they gave us a decom
decompensated decompressed version
decompressed version of that while the
state had the enhanced version that's
what the but then I remember that like
the enhancements was like a computer
manipulation yep absolutely like they
were crazy they were adding data to it
and then we found out because the the
the the the portly uh lawyer I believe
it was when he showed his lunchbox is
that is that his name he had a yeah oh
James cross 88 cross oh he's got his
head on his computer he had programs
yeah he had a he had an app called
handbrake on his computer which
decompresses files and makes them all
blurry like that okay not decompress it
compresses compresses right so so it
goes from high resolution to low
resolution and then makes it hard to see
what's going on so was this the state
prosecutors denying the evidence or was
this uh the FBI and and this was the FBI
trying to clear the record in order to
exonerate you no the FBI was the FBI was
not trying to clear the record to
exonerate me the FBI was after me
um this was the state working with the
FBI okay
to to try to pretty much throw me at
prison the rest of my life but why
you know because that's what those are
BLM supporters symbolic I think it would
have been smaller it might get yes you
saw the photo of the FBI agents taking
the knee during the black lives matter
protest that should tell you a lot it's
a cult they're a cult too isn't there a
photo of the director of the FBI with
like a Biden mug out there somewhere I
thought I saw something is that the
former FBI driver I wouldn't be
surprised I mean this is the same year
where we learned all the uh how many FBI
people were involved in the Whitner
Whitmer oh yeah kidnapping but all but
two or something like that you know it
bums me out because you know in my mind
growing up the FBI was this this quirky
conspiracy theorist who believed that
aliens existed you know and then he'd
reluctantly tell his boss he tell his
boss who then reluctantly would call an
FBI teams to actually be forced to
investigate crimes and they never wanted
to believe him but then you realize the
FBI actually forever you know since J
Edgar Hoover was just like a political a
political weapon there's definitely a
picture of Comey wearing a Biden Harris
shirt with a Biden Harris mug drinking
coffee but he was out after like he
wasn't he wasn't he was already out of
office at this point he got fired but I
mean I think the crazy thing is what
we're learning now with Trump is that
while he was President the FBI was
engaging in these psychological
operations to discrediting the hunter
Biden laptop story with Twitter and all
that stuff they're now lying about it
and the funnier thing is guys I mean
come on Donald the left keeps saying it
but Donald Trump was in charge he was
the president and it's like not like
they were listening to him but at the
very least couldn't Trump have have done
something I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
blame Trump for being the victim of this
this political malfeasance or whatever
but when you're the president you gotta
you gotta go through this stuff he
should have fired everybody right away I
understand the Russia gate stuff jammed
him up and tied his hands and all that
and that was the intent but Trump could
have at least known what they were doing
with with social media he he should have
known they were Banning his biggest
supporters and trying to affect the
outcome they're trying to affect him
politically did he say he was going to
break up the FBI if elected again he
should I'm I'm all for that you should
say that
that's what that's what JFK said yeah
and then well yeah and that was also
that's post Northwoods yeah oh man
project north of the woods if you don't
know what project Northwoods is it's
definitely something worth looking up
because it's a great conversation
starter especially operations in 30
seconds what is it in 30 seconds false
flags on American children Chiefs of
Staff is essentially planning a false
flag uh on the United States in order to
get us into a war with Cuba this is the
problem I'm having is that domestic
terrorism is good for business for the
FBI and the CIA because it gives them
something to do so that gives them a
reason to hire more agents and to get
more funding which is why I keep
thinking if we get rid of them which I
want to those people will just be like
terrorists roving the country but what
do we when we just have another secret
police step up if we got rid of ours
it's probably inevitable but we have to
start over but you know the people need
look the government the idea of the idea
of of power coalescing just inherently
means corruption forms corruption will
happen and then the people need to come
out and say okay we're we're choosing
now to to shut the corruption down it
takes willpower and then when you weed
out that corruption the American
Revolution for instance they say to the
king no we're done and then they they
say we weed that out we get the
foundation of this country and a couple
hundred years later we now have very
serious corruption in this country it's
going to take in my opinion fifth
generational tactics meaning influence
building uh shows like this people
watching spreading the word to their
friends that's the path towards success
right now and when enough people come
together
and then say no more to this corruption
the system falters and I think that's
what we're witnessing right now with the
exposure of all this we're watching it
crumble this is the revolution this is
the populist Uprising in order for
corruption to keep happening you need
the confidence of the people the people
need to fear you they need to believe
that if they speak out they'll be hauled
off to the gulag but right now we're
starting to see a fifth generational
version of that scene from V for
Vendetta where the the inspector is
saying and then someone will do
something stupid and it shows the finger
man with the badge shoot the little girl
and then all the people just go and just
like start walking to them like they
don't care anymore we're getting to the
point where where people are starting to
feel more and more confident about their
ability to survive while defying the
machine the machine has lost the ability
to scare people it's got it first to a
certain degree we need more people to
just say something as simple as this I
don't care what you have to say anymore
I'm gonna do my thing and we're watching
that happen and the end result I think
is something very very positive when we
talk about you you know the the uh the
fourth turning we're in the the end
stages it's supposed to get crazy this
could be it it may not be as bad as
World War II or the Civil War or the
American Revolution it may just be that
the economy gets bad there's
hyperinflation maybe the dollar tanks
were arguing on Twitter because it's
fifth generational it's it's information
War so maybe all we have to do is
shatter the confidence in these systems
and then eventually when someone comes
knocking your door saying I have a
warrant you go yeah no one thinks your
agency has any has any Merit or or any
more so no one cares what you have to
say like there's that we're going to go
to this court this court has said your
your your warrants are worthless we just
don't listen to you that's why I keep
saying this is like we're in an
existential Renaissance like I see so
many people who were in The Matrix you
want to put it that way who kind of woke
up during covid and they're like whoa
you know they were not politically
active at all and now they uh they're
completely just out of it you know they
want to learn to grow their own food
they want to take their kids out of
school you know and I think that was
talk completely out of their world two
years ago Tim Robbins was red pilled I
guess he called the great red pilling of
Tim Robbins he says like I feel horrible
about the way I demonized people that
didn't get the bag that's commendable
let's just let a great Russell Brand
interview let's talk about the story
here we got from The Intercept Twitter
aided the Pentagon in its covert online
propaganda campaign internal documents
Show Twitter whitelisted sent com
accounts that were then used to run its
online influence campaign abroad check
this out they say Twitter Executives
have claimed for years the company makes
concerted efforts to detect and thwart
government-backed covert propaganda
campaigns on its platform behind the
scenes however the social networking
giant provided direct approval and
internal protection to the U.S
military's network of social media
accounts and online personas
whitelisting a batch of accounts at the
request of the government the Pentagon
has used this network which includes U.S
government generated news portals and
memes memes in an effort to shape
opinion in Yemen Syria Iraq Kuwait and
Beyond let me just stress it may be
indirect but this means the
psychological operations were targeting
American citizens as well you cannot go
on Twitter with a fake middle eastern
account claim the U.S is doing something
they're not and not expect that to
impact U.S citizens this in my opinion
is seditious that the US government is
running influence operations impacting
its own people that should not be
allowed but when we learn that they're
actually providing let's just call
called reimbursement to Twitter for
Twitter engaging in acquiescence to
their to their requests it's a
subsidiary Twitter is allowing the the
US intelligence agencies to run
psychological operations it's being
exposed it was exposed a while ago it's
getting exposed even more today this is
confidence building to me and there's
something else that I think is rather
confidence building that um I learned
thanks to Media Matters because they
wrote this big smear about this show and
they were like uh a 2022 breakdown of
all of Tim castiral's bigots the guests
and they're like they're ragging on
Adrian Curry and Michael magu malice and
it's just like they're making up lies
but one thing they pointed out was that
the yay interview was the number one
live show on YouTube at that moment and
so I was like oh I didn't know you could
track that so I'm tracking it right now
and we're currently number two on
YouTube number one is a Weather Channel
report on the coming blizzard which I
can respect everybody needs to know
about that but then I realized that we
are consistently the top spot on YouTube
and then I thought to myself
if this show can call out psychological
operations can call out Epstein and what
was going on with that and Maxwell yo
the the the sweater is unraveling the
thread has been pulled if this really is
consistently a top live show on the one
of the biggest social media Platforms in
the world I think we're breaking through
and the narrative is crumbling and
that's evidence this is the
counterculture we're burning the
simulation and we need to create it's
just a stable system because things are
going to change things are changing
right now and it's gonna the US is no
longer gonna be the hegemon on Earth we
need to help create an environment where
people can live in peace and and calm
well the truth resonates with people and
the truth has a lot more power than some
State propagandist bureaucratic Becky
sitting at our office eating her potato
chips and spreading some bull crap lies
in order to bomb yemeni's children in
hospitals and schools and and with the
psyop of this story we're number one now
okay we surpassed the weather we're
going to change that good looks but but
this Pentagon Psy up program is against
I've been screaming about psyops for for
so many years they've been denying it's
been happening they're saying no there's
no way we can't be doing propaganda on
the American people Barack Obama signed
the law and I remember talking about
this law specifically with him signing
to directive saying that propaganda
could be used against the American
public I remember covering this the
corporate media responded no that's not
going to happen no way it's happening it
happened and with the U.S pentagon
running psyops on unsuspecting American
people promoting the war in Yemen is
absolutely Insidious and your tax
dollars are literally doing PR for Al
Qaeda because when you look at the war
in Yemen it's the U.S Saudi Coalition
literally bombing the hootsi rebels
creating a humanitarian crisis millions
of people have been displaced tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people have died because of disease
because of lack of clean drinking water
and the United States is working with Al
Qaeda this is even according to the
Associated Press in order to go after
the hootsies that are aligned with Iran
the Sunni wahhabist with Saudi Arabia
are literally doing staged PR photo
shoots in Yemen the United States is
helping their bombing campaign Jared
kushner's helping Saudi Arabia get
better weapons deal in order to help
spread and cause and and inflict one of
the worst humanitarian crises on the
world right now and that's the war in
Yemen and and truly this is a big issue
that deserves a lot more because they're
they're running propaganda to promote
war in Yemen of all places that that is
absurd what do they want in Yemen
to appease Saudi Arabia are they trying
to like take control of the gulf or
something they're they're very very
surface level rudimentary thing is
there's ideological conflict between
certain yemenis Rebel groups and Saudi
Arabia and Saudi Arabia wants to crush
them and the US is helping them do it
and it's causing a major humanitarian
but it's like right they're releasing by
the Gulf of Aiden I want to look at the
map where is Yemen it's like I don't
know better Luke because uh my
understanding is quite rudimental yeah
they want to control the Gulf of Aiden
is what they want they want that trade
route in the in the Suez Canal that's
why they have Israel where it's at the
liberal economic order wants control
It's a larger proxy war between Iran and
Saudi Arabia so the United States is on
the side of Saudi Arabia they're on the
side of the Sunni wahhabist uh the CIA
uh uh you know people in Iran are the
ones that are usually the victims of
this kind of uh larger attack and this
and and they go back and forth there's a
lot of history here and it's all about
who's going to have the sphere of
influences Saudi Arabia and Iran are two
major oil producing countries and they
both have a lot of power they both have
a lot of resources the United States is
trying to choose a winner but Saudi
Arabia is literally going to China and
saying we're going to expand our ties
here we're going to have better security
relations we're going to have better
military relations we're going to have
better trading relations with each other
which essentially is screwing over the
U.S petrol dollar which is also involved
here
I say uh yeah if I think if uh Iran were
to control Yemen then they would they
would have control of that that golf how
do you I I just want to say like it's
remarkable to me I'm sitting here
listening I see Kyle it's just so
incredibly esoteric the things we're
talking about it's very very in the
weeds I just want to give a shout out to
everybody watching you guys have you
give me such inspiration that we can
talk about like yemeni's conflict and
humanitarian crisis and psychological
operations and have the top streaming
show on YouTube this is this is a white
pill I just got to say that I keep I'm
sure you guys are listening I'm sure you
guys talked about it already but I keep
thinking about uh everyone at America
Fest applauding like the anarchist
it was really incredible you know like
there's so many different people with
different thoughts at that place and uh
and seeing you guys on that stage is
really inspiring Kyle Luke sang abolish
the FBI and everyone's going crazy I'm
like I've been saying this for 15 years
but now okay I'll take it someone wrote
in in the YouTube video for that uh live
stream that we did saying that quote I
can finally hear the crowd that Lucas is
always hearing in his head and that's
absolutely true
I have hard I go psycho about this stuff
from time to have a Kyle have you like
psychologically how do you stay calm and
like have you been dealing with not only
what you've been going through
personally because you've been also a
personal Whirlwind in a lot of ways that
I'm not and in addition to the
geopolitical state like what do you do
to stay calm and focused
you know
I
I like uh I like spend time with my
family and dog and my girlfriend and
that keeps me pretty level-headed insane
but I don't
I don't dwell on like what's happening
currently on the outside in the world
like I focus on and I look at it but I
don't let it keep me up at night because
they kind of forced you into it you know
that that too they did force me into it
but but how did you uh how did you end
up deciding to to go out you know that
fateful night and uh provide first aid
and do what you did I mean certainly you
had to have seen something happening in
the world around you
well I was down there cleaning graffiti
providing cleaning graffiti and then I
met with the business owner and then we
talked to them I offered my assistants
to help protect the business and then he
said we'll let you know later and then a
friend at Nick Smith called and he said
hey can you come help us protect this
business me and Dominic black said sure
went down there proof it protected the
business put out fires got pepper
sprayed
um and then I got attacked it so it
wasn't even something like where you had
been watching the news I knew what was
happening and I I knew it was really
disturbing what was happening like they
were burning cities down yeah and nobody
was really reporting on it they were
saying they were peaceful protests but
this this is I think a really really
good example you you're probably the
biggest example of someone being forced
into it but for a lot of regular people
minding their own business saying I
don't want to be involved one day they
look outside and they see you know a guy
ramming his car down a parade or they
see people setting fire to buildings and
then whether you want to or not you're
in it yeah
um look at the walk that just reminded
me look how the media treated the ah
where was it the Waukesha parade attack
exactly they said it was the SUV's fault
and I was just like ridiculous why can't
the media just report on what is
happening what is what they're actually
doing instead of just making it look
better than it actually is you know I'd
like to believe that it's because
good people are secretly being ruled by
a collective of lizard people who have
taken human form and are running the
media but that's just clearly not true
it's just a lot of people believe these
conspiracies it's easier to believe than
the fact that some people are evil
people don't want to believe that their
fellow man would try to destroy
everything just for a little bit of
power but if they're conservative they
absolutely railroad them they put them
through these trials and then these do
they do these cruel and evil things to
them they censor them and they take away
their voice and they put them on
Blacklist yep and then if you're a
leftist you're put up on a pedestal and
then oh you know he was just having a
bad day or he's look at look at look at
the uh Twitter recently I love this
antifa accounts are getting banned you
know uh journalists who are doxing or
getting banned and they keep lying about
it and they actually I I love this so
much they gave themselves their own
encyclopedia entry called Thursday night
Massacre because they got suspended one
time temporarily and they called it the
Thursday these journalists have
narcissistic personal anality disorder
to an extreme degree these journalists
out here they're like like look at you
because of some of these people they've
leaked your address I don't know if they
leaked it but they they obviously they
know where you live two guys showed up
they got shot at long story short oh
interesting that's right you know these
in these independent journalists not
independent there's a lot of great but
these journalists out here who are going
out spreading false narratives and then
complaining that they're getting banned
off of Twitter
when they're like look at Elon Musk look
at that guy who jumped on his car
because he got suspended let me pull up
this story and let's get into this one
this is from The Daily Mail quote it
wasn't me footage shows millionaire Tech
entrepreneurs final words after being
fatally shot by a trigger-happy cop
while defending his home from a
suspected burglar I'm gonna give you the
basis of basics of this story Rajan
moonings Moon and sing probably
pronouncing his name wrong he's dead
he was 33 years old he was a tech
entrepreneur he lived in South Austin
and apparently the story is he heard a
noise and he thought someone broke into
his house so he took his I believe he
had an AR he carried it around and it
looked like he had it low ready
he checked the perimeter of his house
when the cops pull up
the cops within seconds yell dropped the
gun and before he even finishes saying
the word bang bang bang bang
killing this guy they didn't he didn't
die instantly he fell to the ground and
yelled it wasn't me it wasn't me they
brought to the hospital he died this guy
was just legally protecting his own
house and these cops went nuts and Texas
is an open carry state so we had every
legal right to do that I think his
family should actually sue the Austin
Police Department absolutely but but you
know even even outside of open carry
he's not his own property he's in his
own house and these cops just assume
without even stopping that and
questioning the reason I want to talk
about this story if one obviously with
you Kyle here but also because in the
past couple of weeks we had we had
several incidents I I can't talk about
most of them I can talk about the one
where a shot was fired at some Intruders
who broke into my house this they we've
been swatted 15 times we've had the bomb
squad shop twice this is what they are
doing so when I say they are trying to
kill us it's because they want this to
happen they're hoping that the first
time they do it knowing that we live in
a castle doctrine State and we are armed
they're hoping that we go outside to
inspect the screaming and the crazy
noise and the cops get trigger happy
fortunately we have measures in place
and that stupid idea isn't going to work
you take a look at what happens and this
is what's currently happening in in this
in modern politics
absolutely like I agree with you 100
they are trying to get us killed they're
trying to take out Conservancy they're
trying to like this is an attack on the
Second Amendment or a way too
because people I believe everybody
should have a gun but then people are
going to be afraid to go and purchase a
gun if they know if they go and check
their property that they're going to be
shot and killed for simply doing what
they're doing yeah I think these
officers need to be fired immediately
they need at least they only need to be
charged they need to be charged yeah
absolutely charge them I absolutely
agree with you I mean they they took an
innocent life that wasn't doing anything
wrong wasn't breaking any laws was
protecting his own home and property
they were clearly not trained right
exactly do we have a video of this yeah
he didn't point the gun at them he he
didn't fire off around an officer who
clearly didn't know what he was doing
made some people would say he made a
mistake some people let's let's say you
pulled the article because they don't
there's nothing graphic in this video
that I have right here you can just see
the dude Raj look how he's carrying his
weapon he's not even pointing it he's
holding it down at his side he does lift
it up but this is before the full cops
arrive this was him checking his
perimeter
when the incident question happened he
was not pointing anything at anybody
he's on his own property and they and
they shoot him but I want to say
something too because you said they're
trying to take out conservatives it's
more than that I mean I don't look the
the right they they call me liberal the
left they call me conservative Luke's
certainly not a conservative Ian
certainly not a conservative I'm
obviously some weird Centrist that has
you know a little bit of liberal a
little bit of conservative but this is
not a far-right show that's not a
conservative show but is a show that
tries to be honest it's a show that
calls out psychological operations from
centcom happening on Twitter we will
will call out the lies we'll present the
evidence and just try and give people a
real view that is a threat to the
narrative in the machine but I'll tell
you this the fact that they've been
swatting us and it's not working another
white pill moment they can't stop us
a question about this guy that was
killed did he call the police himself
and say that he thought there was an
intruder on his property so my
understanding of the story is that it
was a neighbor
a neighbor saw him patrolling his
property and said it looks like there
may be a break-in or something's
happening so the cops pull up
they see a guy in what looks like
pajamas with a rifle and he says drop
the gun bang bang you might have had
like a coyote on his property or
something like no one knows why he was
out there apparently he said something
like he thought he was there was someone
in his house so he he some the guard
said in a call to dispatcher he almost
seems to be scared of something inside
his house so what what about the
neighbor the neighbor that instigated
this should that person be charged too
did you guys see the video there's an
old I think it was an old black man
watering flowers and the cops shop and
they're like what are you doing and he's
like watering the flowers and they're
like do you live here he's like no this
is my friend's house and they were like
the why are you here he's like my
friend's out of town they asked me to
water their flowers I lived next door
and they're like you're under arrest
they arrest the guy yeah my response
none of your business I believe the
fifth yo and and they were like give us
your ID and the neighbors are like oh
yeah yeah we didn't realize that was him
he is friends with this guy and the cops
are like don't care then there's a video
out of Florida where a guy who's legally
blind is walking down the street with
his walking cane in his pocket he's he's
not Pitch Black blind he's blind to
where everything's blurry but he can
walk without you know hitting something
and so this lady cop she is like what's
in your pocket and he's like holds it up
so walking cane are we done and she goes
give me your ID and he goes what no I
don't have to they arrest him I'm sick
of this man I mean Kyle when you were
turning yourself in the police officers
pepper sprayed you yeah I went up to the
police car
um a pepper sprayed Kyle when he was uh
surrendered to the police that night
when you walked by so after my after
after the incident happened that night I
walked up to the police car hands in the
air I told the officer I was like I just
shot somebody I just shot somebody I was
pepper sprayed I don't remember being
pepper spray but it's not in videos your
adrenaline was probably why so I'm not
disputing that to happen he just sprays
you I read the police report the police
report said they pepper sprayed me and
pointed a gun at me wow they're not
there for you and they don't care
they're not there for anybody for the
city just to think
they they could have they could have the
police could have killed me that night
with my hands in the air if I didn't
step away from the police car I think in
any in any sane Society well me and Tim
got guns uh pulled on us by Chicago
police officers that's Chicago Police I
took out a camera and they thought you
know the camera could have been
something they literally freaking cocked
a gun well well so we get surrounded by
like 12 vehicles in Chicago they start
walking to the car it's an illegal
search in my opinion banging on it
saying out of the car guns drawn they
pull us out they Frisk us they took our
credit card numbers they wrote them down
they wrote down passport numbers from
our IDs and they started trying to find
secret compartments in the car they were
banging on our equipment thinking it was
like fake and then also some cop they
cuffed me and then this guy cuffed me
too yeah this cop box up and he goes you
match the description and then he makes
a gesture and then the uncuffing they'll
like get out meanwhile the car we had
had New Mexico plates and we were in
Chicago and I'm like match the
description of what it was there a crime
with the with the car with the Chicago
plate with it with uh with a New Mexico
plate in Chicago ago that made
absolutely no sense at all 12 squad cars
uh it was again another incident that we
had to deal with one of many that I had
to deal with that is just absolutely
Draconian and insane and we need
pushback against these officers that are
just following orders doing what they're
told I don't understand people who could
back the blue I don't understand
individuals who could still do this
after everything that's been happening
to be honest with you you know I don't
think it's police on their own I think
police are inherently good I think the
law enforcement I think they go in there
to do good things I'm I'm pro-blue
that's okay but I think I'm pro-blue I
think it's in the leadership I think the
leadership there are like appointed
Chiefs who are appointed by these
liberals and these officers are scared
to do the right thing I mean look at the
officer who is fired for donating to my
legal defense he was fired I don't think
it's necessarily the officers but I
think it's the sergeants who are maybe
like sucking up to the supervisors and
people in the department trying to get a
promotion not the officers who are out
there doing the right thing on a daily
basis you're right about the super
supervisors but in terms of the place in
general people are people right there's
a they're good cops the ones that were
defending you and then there are bad
cops who just don't care and will just
follow orders but just like in any
career there's right there's bad
journalists but there's also good
journalists not all cops are bad but
there's also very huge there's also very
few good journalists and let's be honest
here there's also very few good cops
here a lot of them are order followers a
lot of them predominantly generate
revenue for the state and in many
instances in my life and in many
instances of of the average American's
life when they need them they're not
there for them there there are a few
instances where they are and they
deserve to be commended and respected
but very rarely I mean there's laws on
the books here in the United States that
says the police officers do not have a a
duty to protect you and there's been
multiple cases especially with my friend
Joe lazito in New York City where there
was a lunatic a mass murderer running
around that was stabbing my friend Joe
in the head police officers were
standing there watching by then of
course when Joe took them down police
officers took credit for taking them
down even though they never did and then
they claimed Joe was a victim when Joe
was the actual hero of that day Joe
lazito's Survival Story look it up be
prepared to be shocked to see what what
police officers could do so I'm looking
at what's going on a lot now with these
cops and a lot of them are following
orders kovid I think proved too many too
many of these cops will destroy you for
their own personal gain yeah we saw
state troopers go into a bar in New York
because they the bar wanted to open and
New York was like nope you got to shut
down a block away it was a green zone
where businesses were allowed to operate
so the bar owner is basically like okay
we're not selling anything more it's a
hangout everything's free so this so the
the the the local cops were like I'm not
I'm not going anywhere near this they'll
destroy my life my neighbors look mad at
me so they called in state troopers to
come and block the doors and those cops
were like don't know don't care you
can't live your life Kyle but I want to
make sure I say this too because it's
it's not fair to to only highlight the
bad I do want to tell a story of when I
was in Chicago and some guy tried
mugging me and out of nowhere three cops
popped out and grabbed this guy and
slammed him into a iron fence and this
this is like a 55 year old fat white cop
with gray hair grabbed the guy by the
collar spun him around slammed him into
a fence and screamed not in my town in
his face and they asked me if I was okay
he asked me to file a report and they
they legitimately popped that was a rare
experience for me but I don't want to
sit here and just be like all cops are
bad all cops are bad I've had good
experiences but I've had too many bad
experiences they need to not be
empowered to make those bad decisions
and when they make bad decisions and
when they make bad calls they should be
held responsible for it and let's be
honest rarely do they ever get held
responsible for it you look at what
happened in Uvaldi you look at what
happened in Parkland police officers
there literally stood down well those
those guys are getting held accountable
aren't they like they're getting in
trouble getting criminally charged yes
but those are two egregious Mainline big
stories that the world has heard of
there's other stories that that didn't
make the narrative that didn't make uh
National headlines where we see this
time and time time again uh as far as
Uvaldi you have to fight to get Justice
in these particular cases you shouldn't
we should have a system where if someone
makes a mistake or someone hurts someone
else they actually get held responsible
there shouldn't be victims family
members in Parkland coming forward and
demanding Justice for the officers that
were just standing by with their hands
in their pocket that's what I'm calling
for again judge a person by their
character not by who they are but at the
end of the day I think we have a core
systemic uh corruption issue you mean
judge them by by their character and who
they are but not their jobs exactly yeah
yeah yeah I think in some Essence like
most a promissor is a corruption issue
like we don't get good sheriffs elected
there are a lot of great sheriffs out
there but look at the county I grew up
in Lake County Illinois I think that
sheriff is as corrupt as they get I
think it's a department issue with the
head I don't think it's necessarily the
officer I think it may be the officers
scared to disobey out of fear of losing
their pension their job because they
have families they need to provide for
but that's the same that's that's the
same argument that you you know a lot of
German SS officers were making when they
were putting people into camps right
they didn't want to be in camps
themselves they said we'll go along with
it so I'll say you're right it's the
leadership and a lot of these guys don't
know and this is another big challenge I
remember I asked uh I remember asking a
active service member 15 years ago
if you were instructed to shoot a
civilian walking down the street by your
commanding officer would you do it and
they said yeah that sounds like a really
crazy question right like as if to imply
some military officer or some Soldier is
so stupid and so so you know brainwashed
that they would kill an innocent person
but think about what this means if if
you are in an active conflict situation
and you are ordered stop that person
this could be a person onto the weapon
we don't know about this could be a
person who's got a bomb that we don't
know about they're telling you you have
to stop them because you trust the
people you're with not to hurt innocent
people so you think about this is the
issue with police right just sorry to
make the point you got a regular cop
who's like 24 25 years old and he's told
you need to arrest this guy
he's not going to stop and say well my
my Superior officer told me I need to
arrest you but I want to hear your side
of the story no he's going to be like
this guy's dangerous and and they want
me to stop him so I agree with you on
supervisors but there's got to be some
some degree of pushback with a story
like this where the homeowners killed
that dude should not have just jumped
out and shot him that's not an issue of
superior officers no I agree with that
instance and you got to think about this
for a second police officers responded
to a lot of these scenes they're getting
they're getting told what's happening
via radio and a lot of miscommunication
like they like hear it may get lost in
the connection you're talking to 9-1-1
they're talking to the person sitting
next to them they're relating to the
officer the officers adrenaline's
pumping they're going lights and Sirens
to get to that situation they could be
hearing there's a man with the gun this
that and that and then they get there
there's a person with a gun they don't
know what's happening and then
it could also be how the officers train
I don't know how Austin PD trains their
officers but I want to say one last
thing before we go super chats too uh
being from Chicago like when when your
story was going down like I knew all
these areas and so I think that provided
a lot of good context for us because you
get this narrative from the left about
he crossed state lines and I'm like he
was like Antioch it's like 20 minutes
Costco in Kenosha look at it yeah uh
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already my friends please smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this share with your friends get
in your super chats we'll try to uh read
as many as possible got a whole bunch uh
so I really do appreciate it become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you goes
up around 11 p.m Eastern so we recorded
after we wrap up here we do the the
uncensored recorded version and uh I
just want to say this is an amazing
setup so special thank you to TP USA
turning point for uh look at this this
gigantic screen behind us it's just I'm
so jealous and I'm like we really gotta
up our game we're taking that home we're
gonna dismantle we're gonna take it
Shane's gonna carry it it's a bunch of
little screens put together to make one
big one that's so crazy
how about the Charlie Kirk cutouts in
the bathrooms have you experienced that
since yeah
you did I saw I saw the cutout I'm like
let me just yeah keep it in here super
intrusive
eye contact
I'm sorry TP USA I rearranged some
things here but I just couldn't control
myself
this whole compound they have is amazing
yeah so special thank you to Charlie
Kirk when we when we had an error with
this setup yesterday they let us go into
Charlie's personal studio with his name
and everything and got to use his desk
and all that so I I do appreciate it you
know coming out here we needed a way to
do the show and they they built this for
us and so it is an honor and privilege
but let's read some super chats I'm just
going to read them here off my phone
today so let's see uh we got a good one
Jake Swift says Thomas Anderson of
Myspace needs to become the CEO of
Twitter that was Neo's original name in
The Matrix let's make sure our hero
story come to life to wake more people
up and show the truth good to see you on
the show Kyle his name's Tom Anderson
I knew it was Myspace Mr Anderson I
didn't let's see when when Elon said I
want to find a CEO Myspace Tom posted
his Myspace profile picture really and
I'm like him I say yes my friend knows
him
I can reach out yes
let's do it I have a mutual with Tom we
do it Tom on the show yeah oh hit him up
I think I think there's a meme about it
how there it's like he never sold your
data he never spot on you over to the
government he never censored you he just
gave you a place to hang out with your
friends and we and then and then he left
to go live his life yeah the most drama
we had on MySpace was who's in your top
eight top 12 top 24 so he kept batting
it but and Kyle's like what's Myspace
yeah right is it that like before
Facebook yeah yeah yes you know the
timeline dude I would love to talk to
Tom because I remember when Myspace fell
apart it didn't really fall I just
stopped like there's a month where they
just couldn't handle the server load
after Justin Timberlake bought it
Facebook
2016. it was in 2006. all right we got
one from the dojo bird he says this tip
is just for Ian keep rolling 20s bro you
know it baby it was funny yesterday when
Luke was like Ian fell off the stage
we're really worried we're rooting for
you Ian you got injured
I wasn't I wasn't lying
my Constitution check and I felt fine I
was like you did get a little hurt yeah
and I'm rude you know I haven't been
stretching my lower back I've been
sitting a lot that's why I think I got a
little bit of a back tug you looked
really good as you fell though like the
coat the pants oh nice it was like it
was like a movie ball you were like yeah
it just went down you know just
beautiful go for it all right what do we
got Carrie green says Tim the crew and
Kyle awesome show can't wait abolish the
FBI yes I thought it was funny when Luke
said that in the entire audience of
conservatives went they're all screaming
and cheering it was a good moment looks
like this is my moment he floated waited
15 years for this Ian fellow he
levitated
finally they're listening and not booing
they used to boo they're like Boo back
to Blue oh wait then I'm like come on
guys here we go one's important and I
got a question for you Kyle but
Christina H says I cried like a baby
when this kid's verdict came in God
bless you Kyle uh I know that you
probably had a tremendous sigh of relief
or or the feeling must have been
Indescribable but I'm wondering if
you've heard that a lot from people that
they were crying when your verdict came
in I have I have and I think it was
actually a win for America I think
people were like yes finally a win for
America and I think America needed it
because all these things going around
with us like around us just people
losing and just with the election stuff
and people really needed that I was
driving and I pulled over to hear it and
teared up and I was just like man I was
wearing West Virginia I was just like I
needed to stop and just focus I couldn't
be I couldn't be driving we were
watching in the RV as it was developing
right before our major show Canadian egg
says Kyle bro I watched a lot of the
Kenosha stuff live and followed your
story all the way through your verdict
was on my birthday and I cried when you
were acquitted Justice isn't dead glad
you were free man God bless
you know Destiny the comment commentator
yeah I've heard of Destiny he's like a
liberal guy yeah he got suspended on
Twitch because he said your story was
the clearest cut case of self-defense
he'd ever seen so they suspended his
account wow that's twitch for you man
that's crazy think of narrative control
you know real quick think about all the
censorship how many people's accounts
got banned off of social media I mean
just recently on Instagram on meta I
could actually put my name Kyle
Rittenhouse in my own profile wow
that's crazy you know it's funny I
posted something on Twitter about it a
day before and then I tried it the next
day so I know I feel like they're
definitely looking at my posts because
they're like oh shoot he noticed we're
gonna go ahead and lift this real quick
all right son of Nothing says audio is
hot high pass Shane and lower DBS I told
the crew that uh because I saw in the
beginning everyone was complaining about
that so I told them and I think they
fixed it Midstream okay I think I know
son of Nothing shout out Pat pretty sure
that's what audio is always really
really hard it was really hard
everyone's complaining in the beginning
of saying it was really bad shout out to
Serge and Kellen working every machine
and a new machine new environment surge
behind the scenes the ground running
stunning and brave says take my money
before it gets sent to ukrainia
yeah your money's getting sent no matter
what huh how about that
here we go what do we have here
what is this one
uh I don't know what that one's about
let's see this
AK storm 49 says watching 30 minutes
behind but I'm glad to see Kyle on the
show can you get the AK guy on Tim cast
IRL he'd be great to have to discuss
two-way in firearms in general Brandon
Herrera yes we're supposed to do it uh a
while ago we were supposed to do the
interview last year I think something
else came up uh but you know Brandon I
think you're doing some work with him
aren't you yeah yeah I know Brandon I
was actually just out of the range with
him a couple weeks ago great guy he is
hilarious um I saw I so I went to his uh
place just like hung out for a little
bit his uh his uh Warehouse where he
makes AKs he didn't have the ak-50 there
for me to see and I was a little jealous
yeah that looks like a yeah
pretty incredible all right Machinery
there I'm really excited for these ones
Doc Holliday says Luke can't control his
TDS poor sop Luke's TDs is a severe
mental sickness
that's that's your opinion
okay that's what he says every time
that's that's fine that you believe that
I like to live in in reality but can we
just shout out Kyle Kolinski who called
Luke a trump supporter I know Kyle Kyle
that come on man
that's not cool that was really cool um
we're gonna have him on at some point uh
I was talking to him like I messaged him
after he did that I was like bro Luke
has TDS and he and he started laughing
and he was like we talked about it and
he was like okay
you know but uh he he because because
Luke criticized uh Trump for the nfts I
guess Kyle thought you were a trump
supporter criticizing him now I'm sorry
I'm criticizing your savior I apologize
that I'm that I'm stopping the group
think I'm so sorry I'm I'm breaking your
your cognitive what is it dissident I'm
so sorry Lucas just for the I don't I
don't Luke does not have TDS he's just
calls out what he sees I know you pretty
well I mean he's very objective about
stuff and and he gives credit to Donald
Trump When Donald Trump does good stuff
yeah just like you should with anybody
all right zero one of one says are you
familiar with shorting stocks the banks
are shorting the American dollar borrow
big now run the value down then pay it
off at a discount
is that what they're doing
what was the first part they run the
value they're shorting US the US dollar
oh so many people are right now
digaboom says Alex Jones said Epstein
was a pawn and did a whole explanation
of their operation and his level in the
hierarchy but you know conspiracy theory
we could do a behind the scenes show or
like on timcast.com with Alex the whole
episode about Epstein just get to the
bottom of it oh go deep I don't know if
there's a bottom one is he supposed to
come on yeah I think I think we're gonna
have uh out to come out soon
you should also try to talk to Whitney
Webb about it yeah yeah she would be a
great guy I recommended her as a guest a
couple weeks ago uh but I think she's in
Chile yeah but uh yeah I've been trying
to get when you web last year uh the
flyer on the show loved everyone she's
incredible have you been on Infowars no
uh have you Kyle I have not it would be
a good show that'd be fun Alex is
awesome have you talked to Alex at all I
have not
Michael Williams says lawyer here
lawyers can't ask leading questions of
their own direct Witnesses but they can
and do ask leading questions of the
opposing party's Witnesses on
cross-examination hmm
well there you go that's why it's always
annoying when cross-examination is just
like did you stop beating your wife
yesterday the day before you're like
neither and then they're like so you're
still beating your life that's not what
I said
it's so painful especially like did you
stop beating your wife yes or no it's a
simple yes or no question did you stop
beating your wife
that's that's the famous one and if
you're like no because I never said
they're like honest no yes or no you're
like I never no
and then just say you don't understand
the question and then the implication to
people watching is that you do curious
what would happen if that question came
up and you just said yes did you stop
beating your wife when did you stop I
never started
yes when did you stop uh I don't know
how you knew this but it was actually
just the other day
all right uh what do we have here
waffle sense that says the government
killed JFK and people think the
government was listening to Trump as the
president the presidency is not where
power lies it is simply a power that
lies oh look at that I was clever
they're very clever
Let's uh grab another one here what do
we got
all right oh well we gotta let's see
what we have here dalamar says they
wanted to throw Kyle in jail for life
because they wanted to send a message
that no one else should ever defend
themselves or their loved ones or town
in a violent manner ever they wanted a
pacified and scared population go to
work and take meds don't breed which is
so crazy that is so crazy for National
Defense why would you want that you want
your armed civilian populace to be able
to defend itself if there's an event
unless they're approach China because
the government wants control of
everything or their their pro-china and
they want the U.S to be weakened so that
it can be gutted
they're gutting us economically that's
for sure
there you go
all right it feels so quiet in my
headphones like because there's no
ambiences
yeah keep doing that as I'm about to
read you know how much are saying your
mic looks like it's wearing a hat it is
wearing a hat oh yeah all right Dan
Diggler says Tim you should help Steven
Crowder set up his own independent site
on Parallel economy since he left the
blaze I love what you guys are doing and
can't wait to get back stateside when
your coffee shops are open I am so
excited for the coffee shops a lot of
work's gotta go in to to to make that
but uh we're we're gonna get it going
and hopefully in a couple weeks we'll
have the coffee to sell it's being
worked on right now and then hopefully
within a month or two we will have a
functioning open coffee shop People can
hang out at I got a product Luke's enema
coffee enemas that's a good idea yeah
and we'll we'll it will be private
booths where people can go in and Luke
can administer his coffee enemas
yeah we were going to do we're Luke was
we're talking about doing a loot coffee
but it'd be decaf
um oh yeah
yeah looks decaf espresso blend let's do
it decaf it's good for your digestion
yeah and it's excellent for avogados
perfect that's great a scoop of vanilla
ice cream splash of decaf on top won't
mess with your sleep
oh yeah but then we'll clean you out you
know Crowder Crowder left the blaze man
he's launching mug Club forever I I just
assumed he's doing his own thing right
I I you know look like I don't think
Crowder needs our help I want to make
movies with you Steve yeah he's
substantially bigger than our show he's
a huge great dude Steve and Dave dude
let's do it dung is fun says Disney has
been part of propaganda and also racism
why haven't they been canceled watch
black and white films and you wouldn't
understand
I think people have complained about old
Disney they complain a lot about Disney
yeah
just leave me alone says Kyle is getting
information overload from you guys yes
did you feel like that yes
yes like we may as well be speaking
German we were going easy too just just
a heads up I actually think this is
really fun it's very educational you
know especially for my youth you know I
have a question for you Tim what is your
guys's viewer range like do you guys
like range from like 18 to 30 or like 30
to 70 like what's age range it's the
obviously we we get every every age
um I don't I I I think there are people
who are under 18 for the most very very
tiniest liver the 18 to 54 then there is
I think the biggest is 24 to 35.
then it's uh I think 35 or 36 to 54 and
then 18 to 24. uh so that's the dude so
most people I'd say the average person
watching this show is a 30 year old guy
named John we did meet a few 50 year old
women this weekend who was saying like
you we have a lot of 50 women watching
you so they do they do out there that's
my Geographic a lot of older women yeah
good good news though is that uh it's
awesome when the show started it was 90
mail now it's 80 male that is extremely
good news yeah more more women are
tuning in to the show there was there
was uh one lady that came up to you and
I was there and she was like 55 year
olds dig you yeah I remember that and
you're making some comments the older
ladies there Kyle do you wish to expand
on those
that's where the numbers are on I think
a lot of older women can identify with
feminism as it was like second wave
feminism legit like equality of
opportunity for people that's what and
so they see what we're doing people are
putting their age in the chat so uh I
think that's pretty cool so put your age
in the chat just so we could see that
perspective of who's here uh 24 52 41 71
shout out 71. and how many of you guys
have 777 shout out people watch the show
with their kids some people was like hey
my one-year-old he looks up when you get
passionate don't do that anymore I'm
like sorry bro that's right
when I was in Georgia doing the last
book they were like you got to tell Tim
like there's a there's usually like six
of us that are watching so the
viewership is like more you know right
it's like families are literally
watching together and I saw it happen or
just people put it on their speaker
phones and they're working doing all
this yeah that's what we've done on the
farm when we were in New Hampshire we
were working on trucks and we just put
it on a big speaker and a bunch of us
were working on the truck and listening
to I am you know whenever I come out and
see stuff like uh like what turning
point is doing when I went to the
Blazers Studios
these are really important for me
because it's deeply inspirational and um
I don't I wouldn't I wouldn't say
jealousy is the right word because I I
see what they have and I want it I don't
want theirs I want my own and so turning
point has this massive compound it's
insane how huge this is they're able to
like build this entire Studio rig with
this big screen and I'm like we need to
be able to do this stuff too I I I
wouldn't call it jealousy I don't want
theirs I wanna I wanna I see what they
have and I'm like this is what we need
to build so we can do more shows we can
bring on more journalists and uh we've
been working on the the non-profit for
fact checking and building the browser
extension and doing all that stuff so we
can start rating news agencies it's just
taking a really long time to file you've
got to file in every single state then
we got to do fundraising but I'm deeply
inspired by what they got going on
turning point so I'm really excited to
see what we can end up doing in the
future I think these coffee shops are
going to be amazing because I want to
create physical places where people can
hang out and you know that when you're
hanging out there you guys share values
because we're gonna put we're gonna put
signs up in the window We're Not Gonna
We're not gonna be ashamed to be
pro-american we're not going to be
scared of the far left lunatics we're
not going to put please don't hurt us in
the window we're going to put come hang
out if you like if you like America and
you believe in in meritocracy play some
games have some coffee watch some shows
are you going to take over the Starbucks
that's the real question I want to put
my stores next to Starbucks and I want
to undercut them into Oblivion
I want to subsidize my stores to make
the corporate stores unprofitable not to
call you Tim but I noticed you're
drinking something right there yeah
you're very caffeinated there in the
shot this you're drinking some high
fructose corn syrup
glycerate filled corporate coffee two of
those things come on get that poison out
of here and plastic plastic leaching
water come on we could do that really
had um Shane what are you drinking there
Mellow Mushroom come on some Charlie
Kirk's brand I guess sparkling water
Charlie Kirkland
yeah but in your shot Tim you have two
coffees Starbucks Coffee well they're
not this one's yours I don't know that
yeah and uh I only drink a little bit
and I start because it's just all sugar
yeah it really is
I had a Nespresso which is arguably
worse but healthy I guess delicious yeah
but we're launching our own coffee thing
so in the future we're gonna have a
well I don't want to say too much until
we're ready to launch it but we're gonna
Tim's got him next to him because he's
taking him to the shooting range
because we're gonna say no to Starbucks
have you ever liked Cuban coffee Cuba I
think so I came in Miami all the time
it's really good delicious it's sweet
it's like oh yeah it's like brewed over
I think it's like brewed over sugar
right have you ever had Turkish coffee
no tell me about it so they put the
grounds in the cup with the hot water
and then the ground sink to the bottom
and the coffee goes to the top and you
just you sip it and so I love uh
when people when I was in turkey and
people would be like you want to get a
Turkish coffee and say okay and they
would get it and I'd be like don't
forget to stir and they'll go oh okay
and they'd ruin it they'd Stir It Up and
get all the grounds mixed up and then
what there's grounds in and I was like
I got you gotcha all right let's read
some more of these here super chats
fluffer boy 2004 says now people will
get what my name means wasn't it like
someone found his email address yeah
yeah somebody found a computer somebody
found the prosecutor's email
and I saw that I I started laughing do
you know like the Scandal that's going
on with the judge what does it just
handle that what do you mean like
there's like a scandal thing like
apparently he's sleeping on some judge's
couch what wait it's a scandal because
he's on someone's couch he's sleeping at
some judges
the judges yeah I'm not Trader on a
different judges couch no no wait wait
fluffer boy is sleeping on a judge's
couch so Banger is sleeping on a judge's
couch well as of last time I read this
I'd feel bad for him if he wasn't so
evil you know but the thing is his like
wife divorced him previously and like he
has a house that's the funny thing he
has a house but he's pictured with this
judge in like all these places like at
the lake doing all these things and you
know people are really starting to think
like he's got a friend in the judge did
you get the vibe that he was just trying
to do his job and get you prosecuted or
that he actually believed it I think he
was so I thought he may have really
believed it I think he told himself
enough times he looked in the mirror I
am right I am right I am right that he
believed it
you know he probably gave himself a pep
talk every time he uh went into court
he'd go into the bathroom and he would
say
you could do this believe in yourself he
called himself fluffer boy in the mirror
it's like you got this lover boy he'd
look in the mirror and go I'm not evil
I mean a little bit maybe but I'm not
but
it's okay because I Get Money
that's crazy to me I don't understand
people could do something like that and
then just waste taxpayer money
all right let's read some more JR says I
did not cry when my father died but when
Kyle was pronounced innocent live I
shouted effia and broke down it was
because it gave me hope the system isn't
entirely broken it just needs salvaging
you're here man it's a crazy day I like
ran out and I was like oh
oh we got the news homie's free that was
amazing people were crying
Ian fell down and went from his face it
was it was
that's a that's a big deal my knees
buckled in because I was I I didn't know
if the jury was going to do the right
thing
and I would I walked in there and I was
just like I was prepared I was like I
don't know what can happen like they
could be like they can be like afraid to
like deliver a not guilty verdict and
this can this is going to determine my
life and I'm like thinking of like the
future you could have had like leading
up to that day or like trying not to
think about it at all you know I was
just focused on the trial yeah I was
just focused on getting found not guilty
but when those that that couple seconds
leading in walking into that room like
okay anything can happen here
um I'm either going to walk out of this
courtroom a free man or I'm gonna be
Shackled and put in a prison cell yeah
so uh Darth Maul says you have to watch
the full video Raj fired two rounds the
neighbor mentioned that to dispatch and
dispatched to the cops they came in
expecting a gunman
all right well that changes things you
know that that's the entire two rounds
the neighbors called yeah cops showed up
yep still shouldn't have died though but
that's Rachel Cox says blizzard coverage
Memoirs what will come will come
watching the penultimate timcast IRL of
2022 is more important yeah tomorrow is
going to be the last show of the year
because um we we have like these
fleeting opportunities to do the week
after Christmas but the challenge is
this you've got Christmas on Sunday and
then Monday is when everyone's traveling
back so we we can't we can't get get a
guest to come out on the day they're
coming back from Christmas with their
family it's like instead of flying home
for Christmas fly to our compound when
you're tired and we can't do that so
we're like okay we'll try Tuesday we had
a guest guest canceled saying guys I
can't travel Christmas family stuff
sorry I thought I could then we had a
guess on Wednesday but I'm like we can't
just do a show on Wednesday and then
we're done for the week that's
ridiculous it'll just be like us sitting
around staring at the wall being like
well we can't really do anything and
then uh ultimately I was just like guys
should we just take the week off it's
it's after Christmas everyone's boot
their families and you got New Years
coming up let's just go see our family
it's actually more how many days we have
we'll have the whole week after wolf
take Friday off take all week next week
off and then days after that you back on
Sunday it's like nine days I think it's
uh it's Saturday Sunday until then
through the next seven days and I'll be
back on the second is it January I
believe that's the longest break you've
taken yeah from this show for sure oh no
Friday well yeah nine days You're Gonna
keep doing that well I mean we took off
uh it was we did two days the week of
Thanksgiving because same issue
Wednesday was the travel day for
Thanksgiving so nobody wanted to come on
the show and I don't blame them and I'm
like we could do a show with with our
employees but then we're asking them not
to go see their families so I was like
Hey Oh you came back on Cyber Monday
with yay
is that what we did Monday was yeah I'll
say this
um in hindsight if I could go back in
time
I would prepare the show and then I
would have Shane take my seat
no no you guys are doing fine we need a
Shane yay interview because you want to
spend time with him and you guys have
like a I think like I told you guys I
think the camera sometimes just changes
people changes a lot but sometimes
here's what I think I don't know
anything about yay he was just another
guest I was having on the show and he
knew I didn't know or care about his
career or anything but you were a
genuine fan who knew so much about him
that I think he realized you actually
knew what you're talking about yeah I
think if you talk to him for five
seconds as that show was starting he
would be like okay this guy knows me
right and I wasn't even trying to be
like you know fawning I was just like I
see how you apply your career and I
think how you could apply it to politics
by deconstructing music and you know all
the stuff that I went to that you can
read the article on Tim cast and and
Media Matters uh when they were when
they were writing about all of the
guests we had they included that special
smear of Ian where they said Ian
Crossland is quoted as saying that yay
will save the Jews or something yeah I
wanna I think they're refocusing Jewish
people on God is what makes them Jewish
and people are like no you're Jewish
culturally but I think you're as right
in Israelite culturally you're from
Jacob up the descendants of Jacob who's
Israel those are the that's the culture
then the religion from you know they
also said I worked for Infowars I never
worked for any wars no way yeah that's a
false statement of yeah they're lying
about recently they said that they said
it in the article
they called Dave Smith uh Nazi
sympathizer or something and like Dave's
is he Jewish he is that's so insane they
wrote a hit piece on me last week too
they're really getting us they called
Michael Mouse election deniers media
Media Matters yeah yeah they called uh
Michael Mouse on election denier it's
just what Michael malice is not an
election we're here to keep the haters
employed yeah I guess so but I was like
basically Media Matters put together the
best of list Seth Dillon commented on it
and I was like the bigger insult is they
didn't put you top of the list man you
deserve better right Babylon B come on
they're the ones who sparked Elon taking
over basically yeah remember the top of
the list yes
[Laughter]
all right what do we got we'll grab some
more Super chats here a lot of people
are just basically saying Kyle's awesome
Robbie Martinez says Kyla's not wrong
former dispatcher here and total reform
will not happen among police until the
brass have retired
absolutely
absolutely so there you go
or they get replaced with worse monsters
that will commit more atrocities on
human beings and then follow all the
orders and then screw Humanity over and
then put everyone in the trains and then
the camps that's when we come in and we
elect people that are actually good
honest people who are going to give the
to a point good Chiefs electing good
sheriffs it's our job as Citizens to do
that and do our research all right let's
grab uh one more Super Chat Timothy Soto
says the Omnibus Bill has gun control in
it and money for the ATF if they don't
read that bill and they vote on it I
think that we should treat that like a
felony personally agreed but you know I
yeah they should abstain they should
just say no sorry keep me away from it
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com and you will get
to watch the uncensored members only
portion of the show plus our massive
library of all the different guests
we've had uh over the past couple of
years doing the show so it is really
really big it's a big content it's a bit
uh contemporary to the time they were on
the news and everything we talk about
but it's interesting too when we talk
deep philosophy and things like that not
only will you get that you'll also get
Shane's show tales in the inverted World
you'll get the cast Castle Vlog but more
importantly you're basically helping us
build the culture and uh
create the things that we think will do
better we're going to make these coffee
shops the idea behind this was how do
you how do you create something akin to
church for people who aren't religious
how do you create a place where families
can bring their kids together where they
can share ideas where they can organize
together and make a difference
interestingly Turning Point USA has done
that for schools and young people and I
think if we can do these coffee shops we
basically create an idea I had called
Saturday morning cartoons where families
can come hang out in the morning bring
their kids their kids can watch approved
cartoons with good messaging the parents
can meet each other share ideas this can
create better organizing among the
community to push back on the stuff so I
want to have 100 200 300 of these
physical locations becoming a member
basically helps us do all of that so
become a member at timcast.com smash the
like button you can follow us at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
everywhere at timcast Kyle do you want
to shout anything out
uh yeah if you want to help me in my
civil lawsuit that I'm facing right now
you can go to
www.givesanggo.com
leave a message or a kind word a kind
prayer or donate to help me fight this
and take on the left in court again
they're basically suing you over the the
Kenosha incident even after you work
with it yes the family of Anthony Huber
was he the guy that tried to hit you
with a skateboard yes he didn't try
though he did hit you didn't he he did I
do have a dent in the back of my head
wow wow that's crazy was it give send
go.com Kyle Rittenhouse yep uh
www.givesandgo.com
house there's another way to help
support uh the movement or uh
individuals is helping support Kyle
Rittenhouse who's still fighting this
fight quite literally so thanks for
coming on man I appreciate it what's
going on I'm Shane Cashman here and
online and I'm stoked to be here and I
hope you support Kyle uh I am the author
of tales from the inverted world you can
watch season one on YouTube season two
is on Tim cast exclusively we got the
tales from the inverted world book at
invertedworldbook.com and uh the new
book should be out in a bit and uh in
the meantime you can also look at the
the yay story I published on timcast and
you're also covering the Kerry Lake
trial you even got to meet with their
campaign I talked to Carrie like
yesterday that was incredible and was in
trial day today and most of tomorrow so
awesome that'll be awesome too cool
sweet my website site is Luke
uncensored.com by the way I have an
online journalism course on there called
change media University I'll send you
that after the show it's free for
members and I also did a very important
video on there that is titled this is
why you need to be strong it's a very
good video it's going to be a free video
for people who are signed up on my email
list on we are change.org but if you
want to watch it now you got to become a
member on lukeansensor.com it's
definitely worth the watch because you
sign up that's why I'm here thanks for
having me you can portal through to any
of my social media from Ian
crossland.net and again thank you so
much to Turning Point USA Charlie thank
you so much for inviting us and letting
us use your studio uh it's been
incredible it's been inspiring I made
inspired to make videos I made a video
today on my YouTube channel at Ian
Crossland you can find it and uh I hope
go there check it out hit me up anytime
thanks again and I hope you appreciate
my rearrangements here
oh search how you doing buddy search
been working hey look at that there we
go yeah we were trying to figure out the
Audio I think we were just monitoring on
uh on the Razer laptop and it was giving
us all this weird Echo and stuff pulled
up my phone it was fine so aside from
all the initial stuff that I fixed like
the overdrive and all that stuff
initially it seemed like it was fine so
thanks for hanging out with us guys we
appreciate it yeah so tomorrow will be
the one show we did here at tpsa
headquarters that we'll go off without a
hitch so thanks for hanging out
everybody go to timcast.com because
we're going to have a members only
uncensored show coming up in just a
little bit and we'll see you all there